I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Dah na, nah na, nah, dah na, nah, nah, nah. Oh, Michael.
我是珍娜·菲舍，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，也是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。哒、娜、纳、娜、纳，哒、娜、纳、纳、纳。哦，迈克尔。
Michael. Bless his heart. You guys, today it's employee transfer. It is season five, episode six, written by Anthony Farrell and directed by Dave Rogers. We have lots to say. There was a really good DVD commentary. I didn't do any deep dives, though. What?
迈克尔。真可怜。大家，今天是员工调动。这是第五季第六集，由安东尼·法瑞尔编剧，戴夫·罗杰斯执导。我们有很多话要说。里面有一个非常棒的DVD随片评论。不过我没有做任何深入研究。什么？
I'm sorry. in advance for anyone who likes them and you're welcome, the people who hate them. Who don't? I might need a minute, no deep dives. I have a summary. I know you have a summary and fast facts, but we also reached out to a ton of people.
我提前向喜欢它们的人道歉，不客气，那些讨厌它们的人。谁会讨厌呢？我可能需要一会儿，没有深入研究。我有一个总结。我知道你有总结和速记事实，但我们也联系了大量的人。
So we have lots of good trivia. We did, that is very true. I will give you my summary. Do it. Pam is embarrassed when no one else at corporate wears a costume on Halloween. That is the worst. It was so funny.
所以我们有很多好的花絮。我们确实有，这千真万确。我把我的总结给你。来吧。帕姆在万圣节时发现公司里除了她没有别人穿服装，感到很尴尬。那真是糟透了。太搞笑了。
It was so funny to do and it gets me every time. Holly and Michael deal with Holly's transfer to the Nashua branch. Remember when David Wallace last week saw them kissing after the auction? Yeah, yeah. He was like, I'm not having another Jan and Michael on my hands.
拍起来太好笑了，每次看我都忍俊不禁。霍莉和迈克尔处理霍莉调往纳舒厄分公司的事。还记得上周大卫·华尔士看到他们在拍卖会后接吻吗？对，对。他当时说，我可不想再经历一次简和迈克尔的事了。
No, no depositions. Not on my watch. No. Also Dwight tries to get under Andy's skin by applying to Cornell. I love that storyline. Same. And finally, Pam is gonna team up with Jim's brothers
不，不，没有听证会。在我眼皮底下绝不允许。不。还有，德怀特通过申请康奈尔大学来找安迪的麻烦。我喜欢这条故事线。我也是。最后，帕姆将和吉姆的兄弟们合作
to play a prank on Jim. Telling you those Halperts in the pranks. You know how I feel about pranks. I know how you feel about them in real life. The same as how I feel about tickling. I know, but Pam is like, sign me up. Let's prank away. I know, Pam loves a prank.
对吉姆恶作剧。我跟你说，那些霍尔珀特家族的恶作剧。你知道我对恶作剧的看法。我知道你在现实生活中的看法。就跟我对挠痒痒的看法一样。我知道，但帕姆的反应是：算我一个。让我们大搞恶作剧吧。我知道，帕姆喜欢恶作剧。
That's why Pam married Jim. That's right. Jenna would not marry Jim. No. Because there'd be too much pranking. All right. Fast fact number one, new writer alert, Anthony Farrell. Yeah.
这就是帕姆嫁给吉姆的原因。没错。珍娜才不会嫁给吉姆。不会。因为恶作剧太多了。好吧。速记事实一，新编剧警报，安东尼·法瑞尔。对。
Anthony was with us for season five. He is a writer and a comedian. This was the first episode that he wrote for the show, but I didn't know this till I looked it up. The first thing he wrote was actually the Kevin's loan webisodes. That's right. He wrote a series of webisodes
安东尼陪伴了我们第五季。他是一名编剧兼喜剧演员。这是他为本剧写的第一集，但我直到查了资料才知道。他写的第一其实是凯文的贷款网络剧。没错。他写了一系列网络剧
and some of our writers got to break off and do that. I would have loved to done that. I would have loved to written a webisode. I feel like you had a lot of freedom on the webisodes. Yeah, you did. They were pretty fun, which reminds me we should break down the webisodes sometime.
我们的一些编剧得以分身去拍那个。我很乐意去做那个。我很乐意写一部网络剧。我觉得你们在网络剧上有很多自由度。对，确实有。它们非常有趣，这让我想起我们应该找个时间剖析一下网络剧。
I mean, you don't even have to make it into a question. We definitely should. The accountants, the webisodes, won an Emmy. An Emmy. I'm so jealous that you have an actual Emmy. I know, lady. In your house. I know.
我是说，你甚至都不用把它当成一个问题。我们绝对应该这么做。《会计师》，那个网络剧，赢得了艾美奖。艾美奖。我真嫉妒你有一个真正的艾美奖。我知道，女士。在你的家里。我知道。
It's very pointy. Yeah, those wings are pointy. It's pointy. Angela, do you wanna share that we got in touch with Anthony? Yes, we were emailing with Anthony. We had the wrong email. Aaron Sher to the rescue.
它非常尖。对，那些翅膀很尖。它很尖。安吉拉，你想分享我们联系上安东尼的事吗？是的，我们一直在跟安东尼发邮件。我们弄错了邮箱。亚伦·舍尔来救场了。
Thank you, Aaron. Thank you, Aaron. Got us in touch. It was so great to reconnect with him. He and his family are back in Toronto where he's from and they're doing awesome. He shared with me that he is the showrunner for a show called The Parker Anderson's Slash Amelia Parker.
谢谢你，亚伦。谢谢你，亚伦。帮我们牵了线。能跟他重新取得联系真是太棒了。他和他的家人回到了他的家乡多伦多，他们过得非常好。他跟我分享说，他是名为《帕克安德森与阿米莉亚帕克》的节目的运作人。
And it's actually two shows about the same characters from two different perspectives. I love that. It's so cool. He shared a lot of stuff with us. We're gonna sprinkle it through the episode, but one of the things he said was, before he got the office,
这其实是两部关于同一角色的剧，从两个不同的视角展开。我喜欢这个。太酷了。他跟我们分享了很多事情。我们会在本集里穿插分享，但他说的其中一件事是，在加入《办公室》之前，
he was a comedian but he still needed that day job and he was working at country-wide home loans. And he was so excited when he got the job as writer on the office because it meant he could quit country-wide home loans. He quit like the day before he started in the writers room, right? Something crazy.
他是一名喜剧演员，但仍然需要一份日常工作，他在国家家园贷款公司工作。当他得到《办公室》编剧的工作时，他兴奋极了，因为这意味着他可以辞掉国家家园贷款公司的工作。他好像在编剧室上班的前一天就辞职了？疯狂之举。
Yeah, he was working at country-wide home loans. And then literally like the next day, it was like, I'm gonna go right now on a TV show. But all of that experience paid off because he was often called on in the writers room to pitch like those very minutia office space storylines. And he sent us an audio clips. We'll share those and some other trivia he gave us.
对，他在国家家园贷款公司工作。然后字面意义上就像第二天，他说，我现在就要去给一档电视剧写剧本了。但所有这些经验都得到了回报，因为他在编剧室里经常被要求提出那些非常琐碎的办公室空间故事线。他给我们发了一段音频剪辑。我们会分享这些以及他提供的其他花絮。
It's interesting because actually not a lot of our writers had real office work experience. So he was a find. This was awesome to have him in there. Great perspective. All right, fast fact number two, new director alert. Yes, our very own Dave Rogers, our editor. Yeah.
很有趣，因为实际上我们的很多编剧都没有真正的办公室工作经验。所以他是个宝藏。能让他在那儿真是太棒了。很好的视角。好吧，速记事实二，新导演警报。对，我们自己的戴夫·罗杰斯，我们的剪辑师。对。
If you guys haven't listened to his extended interview in our revisited episode, you should check it out because he is an amazing person and knows so much about the show. I dare say, I don't know if anyone else knows the show as well as him. You should dare to say that. I dare say it then.
如果你们还没听过他在我们重温集里的加长采访，你们应该去看看，因为他是一个了不起的人，对这部剧了解得太多了。我敢说，我不知道还有谁比他更了解这部剧。你大可这么说。那我就敢说。
Say it. I dare say it. She said it. I said it. We were also able to get in touch with Dave. He shared with me that he was so nervous to direct. Very excited, but he had a ton of anxiety. He said he had a panic attack the night before filming,
说吧。我敢说。她说出来了。我说了。我们也联系到了戴夫。他跟我分享说，他当导演时非常紧张。非常兴奋，但有着巨大的焦虑。他说他在开拍前夜还焦虑发作了，
but he just pushed through. I was really curious what the most challenging thing was coming from editing and then directing. Oh, that's a good question. He said the toughest thing about this episode was that there were so many locations. There were these multiple storylines. Michael had this huge emotional journey to go on.
但他还是挺过来了。我很想知道，从剪辑转为导演，最具挑战性的是什么？哦，这是个好问题。他说这一集最难的地方在于有太多的外景。有这么多条不同的故事线。迈克尔要经历一段巨大的情感旅程。
Yeah, and a physical journey. Yes, he said that the most challenging thing for him was just the pace of shooting. And he said there's one thing if you have a ton of scenes in the bullpen and you have to make your day, but it's a whole other thing. If after you finish a scene,
对，还有一段身体旅程。是的，他说对他来说最具挑战性的仅仅是拍摄的节奏。他说如果你在办公区有很多场戏，必须赶在一天内拍完是一回事，但如果你拍完一场戏之后，
you have to pick up the entire crew and all the gear and move to another place and reset up because that eats up so much of your on-camera shoot time. Yeah, but he did feel that coming from editing gave him an advantage because he just knew inherently the kind of stuff that got used on the show. He had watched so many directors do shots that were just never gonna make it in.
你必须把整个剧组和所有装备都搬到另一个地方重新设置，那是另一回事，因为那会吃掉你大量在镜头前的拍摄时间。对，但他确实觉得有剪辑背景给了他优势，因为他本能地知道什么样的素材会用在这部剧里。他看过太多导演拍了根本进不了正片的镜头。
So he said he was able to be really, really efficient. And he got to edit this episode. Oh, that's great, because how hard would it be as an editor to then direct and then give it away? I know, right? Yeah, I would think. He said that Dean Holland assembled a few scenes and then Dave took over and he did a full assembly.
所以他说他能做到非常非常高效。而且他还负责剪辑这一集。哦，太棒了，因为作为一个剪辑师，先去执导然后又交出去，这有多难？我懂的，对吧？对，我猜是的。他说迪恩·霍兰德粗剪了几场戏，然后戴夫接手并做了一个完整的粗剪。
He did like a director's cut and he said not much changed. I doubt it. And he was really, really proud that basically it was his director's cut that went to air. Nice. Well, I have more stuff from Dave too. So we can share that. My fast fact number three is fun facts about Nashua.
他做了一个类似导演剪辑版的东西，而且他说没有做太多改动。我才不信。而且他真的、真的很自豪，基本上播出的就是他的导演剪辑版。太好了。好吧，关于戴夫我还有更多料。所以我们可以分享。我的速记事实三是关于纳舒厄的趣事。
Let's hear them. I mean, Holly has to go live in Nashua. Don't we wanna know more about it? I do. Good. I'm gonna tell you. Okay. Holly is lucky because Nashua was named
说来听听。我是说，霍莉得去纳舒厄生活。难道我们不想了解更多吗？我想。很好。我来告诉你。好吧。霍莉很幸运，因为纳舒厄被《理财》杂志的年度调查
the best place to live in America two times in an annual survey by Money Magazine. And it is the only city to ever win that ranking twice. Holy crap, Nashua. It was in 1987 and 1998. Going strong at the end of the 90s. Really? What else you got?
评为全美最宜居城市两次。而且它是唯一一个两次赢得该排名的城市。天呐，纳舒厄。那是在1987年和1998年。在90年代末期势头强劲。真的吗？你还有什么？
Russian dressing. Originated in Nashua? Yeah. The salad dressing. You're kidding. Russian dressing. No. What?
俄式沙拉酱。发源于纳舒厄？对。那种沙拉酱。开玩笑吧。俄式沙拉酱。不。什么？
You said you didn't have any deep dives. You were fooling. This is a mini deep dive on Nashua. Okay, you're right. It kind of is. And also on Russian dressing, it was created by a grocer named James Colburn. He started mixing it up.
你说你没有做深入研究的。你是在开玩笑。这是一个关于纳舒厄的迷你深度解析。好吧，你说得对。确实有点像。还有关于俄式沙拉酱，它是由一个名叫詹姆斯·科尔布恩的杂货商发明的。他开始把各种东西混合在一起。
It looks like around 1910. Okay. And he started selling it at his grocery store under the name Colburn's mayonnaise salad dressing. Well, that's not a catchy title. So I can see why they had to jizz it up. Soon he started manufacturing it on a bigger scale and shipping it around to other places.
看起来大概是在1910年左右。好吧。他开始在自己的杂货店里以“科尔布恩蛋黄酱沙拉酱”的名字出售它。好吧，这个名字一点都不朗朗上口。所以我能理解为什么他们得把它包装得花哨一点。不久他就开始更大规模地生产并运送到其他地方。
And he got so rich that he was able to retire. Whoa. In 1924. Wow. So just 14 years of selling the salad dressing. And he was like, peace out. Should we make a salad dressing? What's our salad dressing?
他变得非常有钱，以至于可以退休了。哇。在1924年。哇哦。所以仅仅卖了14年沙拉酱。他就说，拜拜啦。我们应该做一款沙拉酱吗？我们的沙拉酱是什么？
What would be in it? What do you like in a salad dressing, lady? You had me at mayonnaise. Okay. So we'll do some kind of mayo based salad dressing. I also like lemon. Do those mix? I don't know.
里面会有什么？女士，你喜欢沙拉酱里有什么？你一说蛋黄酱我就懂了。好吧。所以我们要制作某种以蛋黄酱为基础的沙拉酱。我也喜欢柠檬。这俩能混在一起吗？我不知道。
I don't know. Cause I was going to say maybe like a spicy mustard. Because I know they do a honey mustard salad dressing, but has anyone paired a spicy mustard with a mayo yet? Probably. We need to cut this out. We need to cut this out because we're onto something and we'll never do it.
我不知道。因为我本来想说也许加点辣芥末。因为我知道他们做过蜂蜜芥末沙拉酱，但有人把辣芥末和蛋黄酱搭配过吗？可能吧。我们需要把这段剪掉。我们得把这段剪掉，因为我们发现了一点苗头，但我们永远不会去做。
And someone else will. And then we'll be mad for the rest of our lives. Office ladies. But we need to give it a really long, clunky name. Office ladies, creamy mayonnaise, spicy mustard delight. Yes. And then later. Delight's gotta go on the end.
而别人会做。然后我们就会懊恼一辈子。办公室女郎。但我们需要给它起一个又长又笨拙的名字。办公室女郎奶油蛋黄酱辣芥末美妙滋味。对。然后过一会儿。滋味这个词得去掉。
I don't care what it is. Later we'll call it like Dutch dressing. We'll just pick a country. Denmark dressing. We'll just pick a random country. Pick a country. Okay. This is the formula.
不管它是什么。稍后我们叫它荷兰式沙拉酱。我们随便挑个国家。丹麦沙拉酱。我们随便挑个国家。挑个国家。好吧。这就是公式。
Okay. And then we'll retire in 14 years. Okay. All right, my final fun fact about Nashua is also about Amy Ryan, her character in Gone Baby Gone. Yeah. She is being interrogated. Yeah.
好吧。然后我们在14年内退休。好吧。好吧，我关于纳舒厄的最后一个趣事也跟艾米·瑞安有关，她在《失踪的宝贝》里的角色。对。她正在接受审讯。对。
About a possible drug deal. Yeah. And she admits that she did in fact, make a drug run to Nashua. No. And she made $150,000 on this drug run. Amy, what is it all your roles lead back to Nashua? I don't know.
关于一场可能的毒品交易。对。她承认她确实去纳舒厄跑了一趟毒。不。她在这趟运毒行程中赚了15.7万美元。艾米，为什么你所有的角色最终都指向纳舒厄？我不知道。
Love it. I now need to Google Nashua. Why? I already told you everything you need to know. There's only three things to know about Nashua and I've told you what they are. Well, I need to Google image Nashua. It's really cute.
太棒了。我现在需要用谷歌搜索纳舒厄。为什么？我已经告诉你所有你需要知道的关于纳舒厄的事了，总共只有三件事，而且我都告诉你了。好吧，我需要谷歌图片搜索纳舒厄。它真的很可爱。
I'm a big fan of the Google image button, guys. The button. Like I say it like it's an actual button on my computer. I would love it if it was a button on my computer. Less clicking. Yeah. Okay. Before we get into-
大家，我是谷歌图片按钮的超级粉丝。那个按钮。就好像它是我电脑上的一个实体按钮一样。如果它真的是我电脑上的一个按钮就好了。点鼠标少一点。对。在我们进入——
That's our next addition. Yeah. Like computers for old people. Before we get into employee transfer, I want to share that there is another great DVD commentary for this episode from our crew. And I want to let them introduce themselves because I'm going to be bringing up
那是我们的下一版。这就好比老人的电脑。在我们进入员工调动之前，我想分享一下，我们的剧组为这一集录制了另一个精彩的DVD随片评论。我想让他们自我介绍一下，因为我要提到
some of the trivia they share. Here is the DVD crew commentary for this episode. Am I going to cry again? By the way, I'm Dave Rogers. I'm an Emmy award-winning editor on the show and this was my directorial debut. And to my left here is- I'm Kyle Alexander, location manager for the show.
他们分享的一些花絮。以下是本集的DVD剧组随片评论。我会不会又哭了？顺便说一句，我是戴夫·罗杰斯。我是本剧获得艾美奖的剪辑师，这是我的导演处女作。在我左边的是——我是凯尔·Alexander，本剧的外景经理。
I'm Anthony Farrell, writer of this fantastic episode. I'm Veda Samar, script supervisor. Been on the show for 99 episodes now. And I'm Philip Shea, the property master. And I have also been on the show since the first season. I'm Chuck Hansen-Ary and this was my first full year as a production assistant on The Funniest Show on TV. Oh my gosh, I love it!
我是安东尼·法瑞尔，这集精彩剧集的编剧。我是维达·萨马尔，剧本总监。已经在剧组拍了99集了。我是菲利普·谢伊，道具师。从第一季开始我就在这部剧里了。我是查克·汉森-阿里，这是我作为《电视上最搞笑的节目》的制作助理的完整第一年。天呐，我太喜欢了！
I know, I love hearing their voices. So whenever there's a crew commentary, I just want to let them introduce themselves because it just brings back so many feelings, just hearing their voices. When Dave introduced himself as the Emmy-winning editor, it reminded me, Angela, that we were at that awards show. Remember, we read off the people.
我知道，我喜欢听他们的声音。所以每当有剧组随片评论时，我都想让他们自我介绍，因为光是听到他们的声音就能带回那么多回忆。当戴夫自我介绍说自己是获得艾美奖的剪辑师时，安吉拉，这提醒了我，我们当时也在那个颁奖典礼上。还记得吗，我们宣读了获奖名单。
We co-presented. Yes, and then we got to give the Emmy to our own editors and then we partied all night with them. That was so much fun. That was one of the most fun award shows. Absolutely, without a doubt. Yeah, so that is who does the DVD commentary for this episode.
我们共同担任颁奖嘉宾。是的，然后我们把艾美奖颁给了我们自己的剪辑师，接着我们和他们狂欢了一整夜。太好玩了。那是最好玩的颁奖典礼之一。绝对的，毫无疑问。好吧，这就是本集的DVD随片评论人员。
I'll sprinkle in tidbits they share and then also you guys, the bloopers for this episode are some of my most favorite of all bloopers and you can't find them online, you know? They're not all there. So the bonus for this episode on the DVD box set is so great. I wish all of the driving scenes had been left in
我会穿插分享他们透露的花絮，还有大家，这一集的NG镜头是我最喜欢的NG镜头之一，你在网上是找不到的，你知道吗？它们并不全都在那儿。所以DVD套装里这一集的彩蛋太棒了。我真希望所有的驾车戏都被保留下来，
because they are all gold. I am bummed because I have every DVD set for every season except this one. What? I don't know where my season five DVD went. Oh, lady, I know. Well, while we take a break, maybe I'll order that DVD, Ange.
因为它们全是精华。我很沮丧，因为除了这一季，我收集了每一季的DVD套装。什么？我不知道我的第五季DVD去哪儿了。哦，女士，我懂的。好吧，在我们休息的时候，安吉，兴许我可以订购那套DVD。
Yeah. So I can watch these bloopers. These bloopers are my favorite, some of my absolute favorite. All right, I'll do it. We'll be right back. ["The Star-Spangled Banner"] All right, we are back and you guys,
好。这样我就可以看这些NG镜头了。这些NG镜头是我的最爱，绝对是我最爱的之一。好的，我们马上回来。《星条旗永不落》好了，我们回来了，大家，
it is Halloween at Dunder Mifflin. It sure is. This is our Halloween cold open. Not through the rest of the episode, just in the cold open. Well, we found out why. Let's play Anthony's first clip. He talks all about it. The show was initially,
邓德米夫林迎来了万圣节。确实如此。这是我们的万圣节开场白。不是整集的剩余部分，仅限开场白。好吧，我们找到了原因。让我们播放安东尼的第一段剪辑。他讲述了所有这些。最初，
the entire episode was supposed to be Halloween. So everyone was in their costumes for the entire episode. So Andy was a kitten initially. I think, and the whole B story with Dwight being in the Cornell sweater, that was his costume, an accidental costume initially. And that's where that story came from. So costume wise, we had a thing where once we decided
整集原本都应该是万圣节。所以每个人在整集中都穿着服装。所以安迪最初是一只小猫。我想，德怀特穿着康奈尔毛衣的整条B故事线，最初是他的服装，一套偶然的服装。那个故事线就是这么来的。所以在服装方面，我们曾有过一个设想，一旦我们决定
we were going to just put the Halloween stuff in the cold open, we rewrote the cold open. And that was mostly led by Lee and Jean. And that's where the idea for the three jokers came from. That was obviously a situation that year with that costume being super popular. And they just totally made the most of that situation. It was amazing.
把万圣节的内容只放在开场白里，我们就重写了开场白。这主要由李和吉恩主导。三个小丑的主意就是这么来的。那显然是当年那种服装超级流行的情况。他们充分利用了那种情况。太棒了。
The Charlie Chaplin thing, that was actually a full runner for you, Jenna. We had initially, in the first draft, where you were going to be, it was Halloween all day. So it was just going to be you running around the New York office as the only person dressed for Halloween, trying not to look like Hitler. And it was a fun little runner for you.
卓别林的那个梗，珍娜，其实是为你量身打造的一整条支线。我们在初稿中原本设想的是，万圣节持续一整天。所以那本是你在纽约办公室里到处跑，作为唯一一个穿着万圣节服装的人，努力让自己看起来不像希特勒。对你来说这是一个有趣的小支线。
But I think the story we got eventually with Jim's brothers and that beautiful thing with you taking the heat like that around them and having that nice little moment. I think that to me felt more right. And I love that we ended up going there with the story. Yeah, it was going to be a whole Halloween episode. And then they changed it up.
但我觉得我们最终得到的关于吉姆兄弟的故事，以及你在他们面前承担压力并拥有那个温馨小瞬间的绝妙情节，对我来说，这感觉更对。我很高兴我们最终在这个故事上走向了这个方向。是的，这本该是一整集的万圣节。然后他们改变了主意。
Yes, Anthony shared in the DVD that all those Halloween costumes would actually be distracting from all the other storylines. So they just made it the cold open. And I have a costume breakdown. Oh, good, because I have some good details about some of the costumes. OK.
是的，安东尼在DVD中分享说，所有这些万圣节服装实际上会分散人们对所有其他故事线的注意力。所以他们只把它做成了开场白。我有一个服装拆解。太好了，因为我有一些关于某些服装的精彩细节。好的。
What's everyone wearing, Angela? So we have the scripts thanks to James Apedia. So per the script, here are some details. Stanley, in the script it says, is wearing a creature from the Black Lagoon rubber mask with his regular suit. OK. Creed, per the script, is an amazing Joker from Batman, whereas Kevin is a, quote, lame Joker.
大家都穿了什么，安吉拉？多亏了詹姆斯·阿佩迪亚，我们拿到了剧本。根据剧本，以下是一些细节。斯坦利，剧本上说，穿着黑湖妖怪的橡胶面具搭配他的西装。好的。克里德，根据剧本，是蝙蝠侠里一个惊艳的小丑，而凯文是一个，引用剧本，蹩脚的小丑。
And in the script, it says Dwight is also a Joker. Kelly is Carrie Bradshaw from Sex and the City. Ryan is Gordon Gekko from Wall Street. Very fitting for Ryan. Oscar is Uncle Sam. Meredith, a cheerleader. Phyllis is Raggedy Ann. Andy, per the script, it says, he's dressed as a cat
剧本上还说，德怀特也是一个小丑。凯莉是《欲望都市》里的凯莉·布拉展。瑞恩是《华尔街》里的戈登·盖柯。对瑞恩来说非常贴切。奥斯卡是山姆大叔。梅雷迪思，拉拉队长。菲利斯是raggedy ann（安妮娃娃）。安迪，根据剧本所说，他打扮成一只
with whiskers on his face. Angela has brought back her cat costume, always a classic. And Jim is just wearing a name tag that says Dave. And of course, Pam, the solo Halloween costume wear at corporate is dressed as Charlie Chaplin. Yes. I reached out to our wardrobe designer, Alicia Raycraft. Oh, great.
脸上画着胡须的猫。安吉拉把她的猫服装又拿出来了，永远的经典。吉姆只是戴着一张写着“戴夫”的名牌。当然，帕姆，公司里唯一一个穿万圣节服装的人，打扮成查理·卓别林。是的。我联系了我们的服装设计师艾丽西亚·雷克拉夫特。哦，太棒了。
So starting this season, Alicia took over for Carrie Bennett. Alicia was amazing, particularly, I think, at building wardrobe from scratch. My memories of her when I would visit her in the wardrobe trailer were that she always had one of those fabric mannequins with swatches on it, pinned on it, or on her wall. I am telling you, she was always pinning something to something.
所以从这一季开始，艾丽西亚接替了嘉莉·贝奈特。艾丽西亚非常了不起，尤其是，我认为她在从零开始制作服装方面很有一手。我去服装拖车拜访她时的记忆是，她总是有一个那种插满布料小样的塑料人体模特，别在上面，或者钉在墙上。我跟你说，她总是把什么东西别在什么东西上面。
Yes. And then standing back and looking at it, and then moving a swatch here up and down. She said that with this episode, she had to really ride the line of designing wardrobe, but also making sure that the costumes look like things that we could have put together ourselves. Right.
是的。然后退后一步看着它，然后把一块小样上下移动。她说对于这一集，她必须真正把握好设计服装的界限，同时也要确保服装看起来像是我们自己就能拼凑出来的东西。没错。
The idea is that if Kevin is going to dress like the Joker, it'd be Kevin's effort. It'd be like something Kevin had to put together. Yes. Like you said, the script said that Creed's Joker was supposed to be the best version of the Joker. Kevin's was supposed to be lame. And they're the Dark Knight Joker.
这个想法是，如果凯文要打扮成小丑，那应该是凯文努力的结果。应该像是凯文不得不拼凑出来的东西。是的，就像你说的，剧本上说克里德的小丑应该是最好版本的小丑。凯文的应该是蹩脚的。而且他们都是《黑暗骑士》里的小丑。
Yes. That's what Alicia said. They were supposed to be based on the Heath Ledger Joker. And so she had a picture, and she made a shopping list, and she still had her shopping list. Stop it. I love her. This is what it said.
是的。艾丽西亚就是这么说的。他们应该以希斯·莱杰的小丑为原型。所以她有一张照片，列了一张购物清单，她还保留着她的购物清单。别闹了。我太爱她了。上面是这么写的。
They had to go shop for a vest with a high neck center front, green for Creed, not for Kevin. Because Creed got it right, and Kevin didn't. Correct. They needed a gray or dark lilac pattern shirt, green or olive tie with a pattern, pinstripe navy pants, pleated for Kevin, but flat front for Creed. Argyle socks, black Oxford shoes for Creed,
他们得去买一件前中心领口很高的背心，克里德的是绿色，凯文的不是。因为克里德做对了，而凯文没有。没错。他们需要一件灰色或深丁香色暗纹衬衫，带有花纹的绿色或橄榄绿领带，细条纹海军蓝裤子，凯文穿打褶的，而克里德穿平门襟的。菱形格纹袜子，克里德穿黑色牛津鞋，
but Kevin is to wear his regular character shoes. She said the overall direction in shopping for Kevin was that all of the clothes they purchased should look like they came from his closet. And the direction for Creed was that Creed went out and picked it out specifically for Halloween. Yeah. But for Dwight, she said they went with a nod
但凯文穿他日常角色的鞋子。她说为凯文购物的总体指导方针是，他们购买的所有衣服都应该看起来像是从他自己的衣柜里拿出来的。而对克里德的指导则是克里德特意为万圣节出去挑选的。对。但对于德怀特，她说他们选择向杰克·尼克尔森版本的小丑致敬。
to the Jack Nicholson version of the Joker. I thought something was different when I rewatched it, because the way they drew the smile yes, did not look like the Heath Ledger Joker. That's how they were like, how do we do three jokers, but it's not all the same costume or the same look. But she also shared with me that she brought in a rack of clothes and that Reign really put together his costume
当我重播时我以为有什么不同，因为他们画微笑的方式——是的，看起来不像希斯·莱杰的小丑。他们当时就是在想，我们怎么做三个小丑，但又不是全部都是同一套服装或同一个造型。但她也跟我分享说，她带了一排衣服过来，雷恩确实用她买的所有东西自己拼凑出了他的服装，这与我们和嘉莉交谈时的情况很吻合。
from everything she had bought, which tracks with when we talked to Carrie. And Carrie Bennett said that Reign was always really invested in what his character wore. That's awesome. So let's see, what's next? We got a lot of questions about Andy's kitten costume. A lot of people wrote in to say they
嘉莉·贝奈特曾说过，雷恩对他的角色穿什么总是投入极大的热情。太棒了。让我们看看，接下来是什么？我们收到了很多关于安迪小猫服装的问题。很多人写信说他们
thought it looked a little bit like, my favorite was Katie L said, it looks like an off-brand Rumtum Tugger costume from the musical Cats. She said, in my mind, I like to think Andy was in a school production of Cats and he still had his costume. Katie L, you would be right on there. Dave told me that Greg was very involved in Ed's costume.
觉得它看起来有点像——我最喜欢的是凯蒂·L说的，它看起来像音乐剧《猫》里一个不知名品牌的“Rumpus Cat”（罗姆坦·塔格）服装。她说，在我的脑海里，我喜欢认为安迪曾参演过学校的《猫》制作，他还留着他的服装。凯蒂·L，你可真是猜对了。戴夫告诉我，格雷格对埃德的服装参与度很高。
Really? Yes, that he wanted it to look like it was from the musical Cats. And he went over the top to please Angela. Right. He was not just going to draw whiskers on his face, guys. Alicia said she showed Greg a bunch of photos from the Broadway musical of Cats.
真的吗？是的，他希望服装看起来像是来自音乐剧《猫》。而且他为了取悦安吉拉可谓煞费苦心。没错。大家，他可不仅仅是在脸上画几根胡须。艾丽西亚说她给格雷格看了百老汇音乐剧《猫》的一堆照片。
And Greg picked his favorites, but she did not base this cat on any one character. It was a meld. She built that whole costume from scratch. She bought a unitard and hand-painted it. She used to do textile painting. I mean, that's amazing. And then she found another email that she shared with me.
格雷格挑选了他最喜欢的，但她并没有以任何单一角色为基础来设计这只猫。这是一个融合体。她从零开始制作了整套服装。她买了一件紧身衣并亲手彩绘。她以前做过纺织品彩绘。我是说，这太厉害了。然后她找到了另一封发给我的邮件。
It was an email to her crew detailing how to build the little fur diaper thing that he's wearing. What is it, right? Yeah, I don't know. It looks like fur underwear. And then there's also a rope belt and a tail. And oh, my goodness. Yes.
那是发给她剧组的一封邮件，详细说明了如何制作他身上穿的那件小毛皮尿布似的东西。那是什麽，对吧？是的，我不知道。看起来像毛皮内衣。然后还有一条绳子腰带和一个尾巴。哦，天哪。是的。
She said, please make a loincloth using a thong or small brief underwear as a base, and then swatch Phelps wool crepe and heavy knits on top. And please get faux fur for some gloves. So amazing. So that is how she put together all of those costumes, which were really amazing. And I remember my costume.
她说，请用丁字裤或小三角内衣作为基础制作一块遮阴布，然后在上面拼接菲尔普斯羊毛呢料和重磅针织面料。还要为手套买一些人造毛皮。太神奇了。这就是她拼凑出所有这些服装的过程，这些服装真的太棒了。我记得我的服装。
We did like Pam went to a store and rented a tux, basically. Well, I took a lot of photos this day. I have some great ones of you and Rain. You guys were hanging out by your trailer. I was walking by you guys in my cat costume. And I see Rain as the Joker talking to Jenna as Charlie Chaplin, just casually hanging out. So I took pictures.
我们当时就像是帕姆去商店租了一套燕尾服，基本上是这样。嗯，这一天我拍了很多照片。我有几张你和雷恩的绝佳照片。你们俩当时在你们的拖车旁闲逛。我穿着猫的服装从你们身边走过。我看到雷恩穿着小丑服装和打扮成查理·卓别林的珍娜在聊天，就像平时闲逛一样。所以我拍了照片。
They're some of my favorite. Well, I think he put that one in his book. I gave it to him. Yeah, that's for me. I loved this episode, Angela, because I had been away for a very long time at Pratt. But you know, the corporate offices were over on the warehouse set.
它们是我最喜欢的照片之一。嗯，我想他把其中一张放进他的书里了。我给他的。对，那是给我的。我喜欢这一集，安吉拉，因为我在普瑞特艺术学院待了很长一段时间。但是你知道，公司办公室是在仓库布景那边。
We never got to see you. But you did on this day. Exactly. And I got to participate in the Halloween, which was always one of my favorite things on our show. And I would have been really bummed if I didn't get to see everybody in their costumes. But I got to be in hair makeup.
我们从来没机会见到你。但这一天你见到了。没错。而且我得以参与万圣节，这一直是我在节目中最喜欢的事情之一。如果看不到每个人穿着各自的服装，我会非常沮丧的。但我得以进入化妆间。
And we were in there a long time. Me not so long, but oh my gosh, Ed had to come in really early. Yeah. And so did Phyllis. Like, there was a lot of makeup there. Well, my hair was not easy to wash out. I'll tell you that. Are your eyebrows.
我们在那里待了很长时间。我没待那么久，但天哪，埃德不得不来得很早。对。菲利斯也是。所以，那里有很多妆容。嗯，我的头发可不容易洗掉。我告诉你这个。还有你的眉毛。
I felt bad for your poor eyebrows. It was a real grease paint. They shall act you. Yeah. I have a few little background catches for this cold open. I want you guys to know that at 44 seconds, when Kevin is annoyed that Creed is such a good joker, he brushes past me and knocks me over.
我真替你可怜的眉毛感到难过。那真的是油彩。它们会折腾你的。对。对于这个开场白，我有几个背景小花絮。我想让你们知道，在44秒的时候，当凯文对克里德是个如此优秀的小丑感到恼火时，他从我身边擦过把我撞倒了。
This was like a little running bit Brian and I would have, that if Kevin bumped into Angela, she'd go flying. It was like our own personal bit that cracked us up to no end. When he did it, one of my cat ears fell forward and didn't come back up. And I could feel it laying on top of my head. And I was trying not to laugh. And if you go to 44 seconds, you'll
这是我和布莱恩的一个小惯例，如果凯文撞到安吉拉，她就会飞出去。这就像是我们俩的专属笑点，让我们笑得前仰后合。当他这么做的时候，我的一只猫耳朵向前翻倒了，然后就没再弹回来。我能感觉到它搭在我的头顶上。我当时极力忍住不笑。如果你快进到44秒，你会
see that Angela's ear flops forward. I want you to know that three people that I reached out to on this episode pointed out that moment to me. I know. I know they talked about it in the commentary too. I think it's gone down in the lore of this episode. I know.
看到安吉拉的耳朵向前耷拉着。我想让你们知道，我为这一集联系的三个人都向我指出了那个时刻。我知道。我知道他们在随片评论里也谈到了这一点。我想这已经载入这一集的传说中了。我知道。
And then the other thing was, you guys, they really let Ed as that cat play around and mess with John. And in one take, Ed as Andy came up to Jim and rubbed on his leg, kind of rubbed on him like a cat. And the two of them lost it. It's in the bloopers. But they had a lot of fun with that. One of my favorite moments is when Andy, it says in the script,
还有一件事，大家，他们真的让作为猫的埃德四处走动并戏弄约翰。在一个镜头中，作为安迪的埃德走到吉姆身边并在他的腿上蹭了蹭，有点像猫一样在他身上蹭。他们俩都笑场了。这被收录在NG镜头里了。但他们在这个过程中玩得很开心。我最喜欢的时刻之一就是当安迪——剧本上写着，
Andy walks back to his desk smugly. And Ed's like sashay in that cat costume cracked me up. You guys know we love this fake elevator in our lobby, the Dunder Mifflin Lobby. We've talked about it. Two wooden doors and a guy pulling a rope on the side. And they add all the sound effects later. They added it all in.
安迪洋洋得意地走回他的办公桌。埃德那种猫步的摇曳身姿把我逗乐了。大家知道我们喜欢大厅里的这个假电梯，也就是邓德米夫林大厅。我们讨论过。两扇木门，旁边有一个人在拉绳子。他们后来添加了所有的音效。全都是后期加上去的。
Well, in the script, when Rain as Dwight arrives in the Joker outfit, he just was supposed to hop in the elevator and he was supposed to a la the Joker say, and here we go. And the doors would shut. But it was just kind of falling flat. So they came up with this alt about the magic trick of the pencil disappearing.
嗯，在剧本里，当穿着小丑服装的雷恩作为德怀特到达时，他本该跳进电梯，并效仿小丑说一句：“我们走吧。”然后门就会关上。但这感觉有点平淡。所以他们想出了一个关于铅笔消失魔术的备选方案。
And it wasn't really working still. And so Anthony pitched, what if the doors close as he sang the line? And then he opens them back up to finish the sentence. And they said they played around with this for a bit with the doors opening and closing, which you and I know means that there was someone pulling a rope. Working that pulley really hard.
而且这个方案当时还是不太管用。于是安东尼提议，如果他在说这句台词时门就关上呢？然后他又把门打开来把话说完。他们说他们用门开门关把这个桥段反复排练了一会儿，你我都清楚这意味着当时有人在拉绳子。拼命地操作那个滑轮。
And that's how they found this moment. And I thought that was really fun. That is awesome. Those things that happened on the fly like that in the moment, I love to hear about. Now it's time to get into the episode. We're down in the warehouse. They are loading up a big truck so that they can take Holly
他们就是这样找到这个瞬间的。我觉得这真的很有趣。太棒了。我喜欢听那些在现场即兴发生的趣事。现在是时候进入这一集的正片了。我们来到仓库。他们正在装满一大卡车，以便把霍莉
to Nashua. Yes. We got a fan question. OK. That is very funny to me. Two people. OK. Ian Oh and Mary S wrote in to say,
带到纳舒厄。是的。我们收到了一个粉丝提问。好的。我觉得这非常搞笑。两个人。好的。伊恩·欧和玛丽·S写信来问，
did Holly live in the warehouse? Isn't it odd that this road trip started from the office rather than from her home? This is such a good catch. It's true. Where is this stuff coming from? Oh my gosh. I guess we have to justify it that they went to her apartment,
霍莉是住在仓库里吗？这次公路旅行不是从她家出发，而是从办公室出发，这不是很奇怪吗？这是一个非常棒的细节捕捉。确实如此。这些东西是从哪里搬出来的？哦，天呐。我想我们得这样解释，他们去了她的公寓，
packed it up, but then why did they drive to the warehouse? Why not just leave? This piggybacks very nicely on a question that I had along with Erin S and Amanda E. What is Holly wearing on the day she is moving? She is dressed in her work clothes, same as Pam, driving to Pratt. I know.
把东西打包好，但为什么又把车开回仓库呢？为什么不直接出发？这与我和艾伦·S以及阿曼达·E共同的一个问题不谋而合。霍莉搬家那天穿的是什么？她穿着工作服，和去普瑞特的帕姆一样。我懂的。
What is that? Michael's a casual. He's got his little casual little zipping jacket. Yes. Also, they pointed out, I don't think it looks like she had any intention of helping move any of her own belongings. She is not dressed for a move.
那是什么？迈克尔穿得很休闲。他穿着一件休闲的小夹克。是的。还有，他们指出，我觉得她看起来一点也不像打算帮忙搬运她自己的任何行李。她的穿着根本不适合搬家。
No. She's not. Why couldn't she be casual? What's happening? I thought these were good catches. You know, I talked to Dave about this, and he said that during the prep for this episode, they brought him a bunch of trucks to look at,
不。她不是。她为什么不能穿休闲装？这到底是怎么回事？我觉得这些细节捕捉得很好。你知道，我跟戴夫谈过这件事，他说在这一集的筹备期间，他们带给他一堆卡车让他看，
and they were all giant 18-wheeler moving trucks. And he was like, how am I going to film with that? How do I tow it? What am I doing? But he said he loves this truck that they found. It looked really realistic. He also just loved that the back was open, because then when you've got shots that, you know,
而且全都是巨大的18轮搬家卡车。他当时心想，我怎么用那个拍摄？我怎么拖着它？我在干什么？但他说他很喜欢他们找到的这辆卡车。看起来非常逼真。他也特别喜欢车厢是敞开的，因为这样当你拍那些镜头时，你知道的，
the farther shots of them going down the road, it just like you really felt the move. Yeah. Because you could see her bed. You could see the stuff. Right. They said that they wanted the table hanging off the front, like in the bubble wrap.
更远一点他们行驶在路上的镜头，就会让你真正感受到这是一场搬家。对。因为你能看到她的床。你能看到那些东西。没错。他们说他们想要桌子挂在前面，就像裹着气泡膜那样。
I love it. I loved it, too. Phil Props. You know, we love Phil Props. He shared that Anthony and Dave really wanted Michael to have packed all kinds of crazy things for the road trip. Like him and Holly are little kids, like the finger puppets and the cats and the cradle,
我喜欢。我也很喜欢。菲尔道具。你知道我们喜欢菲尔道具。他分享说，安东尼和戴夫真的希望迈克尔为这次公路旅行打包各种疯狂的东西。就像他和霍莉是小孩子一样，比如指偶、线织花样游戏，
and the movies to watch. You guys, a lot of those are in the deleted scenes. I mean. Of them doing it in the van. And my absolute favorite is the two of them. The windows are down and they're watching a movie, and they are pissing themselves laughing. They are laughing so hard.
还有可以看的电影。大家，其中很多都在被删减片段里。我是说。他们在面包车里做这些事的片段。我绝对最喜欢的是他们俩。车窗摇下来，他们在看一部电影，他们笑得前仰后合。他们笑得太厉害了。
And Daryl looks miserable. And Daryl takes a hard turn on purpose. And the laptop that's playing the movie goes flying out the window. I remember that. It is so funny. I am so bummed it didn't make it in. Dave said they spent three hours on that gag
而达里尔看起来很痛苦。达里尔故意来了个急转弯。播放电影的笔记本电脑直接飞出了窗外。我记得那个。太搞笑了。没能放进正片里让我太沮丧了。戴夫说他们在这个恶作剧上花了三个小时，
and finally had to just let it go. They said every time Craig turned, the computer would slide and never go out the window. It only went out the window one time. Oh my gosh. But it's in the bloopers on the DVD and it's so funny. We had a fan catch from a couple of people, from Erica S. and Mary S. and I have to say
最后不得不放弃。他们说每次克雷格转弯，电脑就会滑来滑去，就是飞不出窗外。它只飞出窗外了一次。哦，天呐。但它被收录在DVD的NG镜头里，真的太搞笑了。我们收到了几位粉丝的细节捕捉，来自埃里卡·S和玛丽·S，我必须说
they're making a good point. What? So it said repeatedly in Goodbye Toby that she's coming in to train for this new position and that they only allowed one day for training. And when she's on the Ferris Wheel with Michael, she talks about how she was unable to be promoted at her former company.
他们指出了一个很好的点。什么？所以在《告别托比》中反复提到，她来这是为了接受这个新职位的培训，而且他们只允许培训一天。当她和迈克尔坐在摩天轮上时，她谈到她在前一家公司未能获得晋升。
Former company. Right, right. But then in this episode, it says she's being transferred back to Nashua as if she's been a Dunder Mifflin employee all along. I don't know guys. I mean, I think they caught a continuity error there. Oh yeah.
前一家公司。对，对。但接着在本集中，说她被调回纳舒厄，就好像她一直都是邓德米夫林员工一样。我不知道，伙计们。我是说，我觉得他们在那里抓到一个连贯性错误。哦，是的。
Here's one of the things I was curious about. Why would Daryl agree to drive Michael and Holly, be in a car with Michael and Holly for seven hours? Well, there was a talking head in the script that didn't make it in. That explained this. Daryl said, I'm driving them up for five times what I would have made at work.
我好奇的事情之一是：为什么达里尔会同意开车送迈克尔和霍莉，在车里跟迈克尔和霍莉待上七个小时？嗯，剧本里有一个Talking Head（独白镜头）没被采用。那个镜头解释了这一点。达里尔说，我开车送他们上去的报酬是我上班赚的五倍。
I thought I made a good deal. Then I realized I'm gonna be trapped in a truck with Michael all day. But he did earn a lot of money. So Michael paid him, is why? They paid him, yeah. Okay, that does make more sense. Well, Michael is not the only person
我觉得这是一笔划算的交易。然后我意识到我一整天都要被困在卡车里和迈克尔在一起。但他确实赚了很多钱。所以迈克尔付钱给他，这就是原因？他们付钱给他，对。好吧，那确实更有道理。嗯，迈克尔可不是唯一一个
who's leaving for the day. Jim comes walking out of the building. He's saying goodbye to them, right? And we find out that Jim is gonna go to New York and he's gonna have lunch with Pam and his two brothers. So we set up that storyline. And I'm bringing this up because at three minutes, 24 seconds, Jim is holding the key chain that he got
今天要离开的人。吉姆从大楼里走了出来。他在跟他们告别，对吧？我们发现吉姆要去纽约，要和帕姆还有他的两个兄弟吃午饭。于是我们铺垫了那条故事线。我提起这件事是因为在3分24秒时，吉姆手里拿着他在第二季的
in the Yankee Swap Christmas party from Oscar back in season two. Oh my gosh, what a great, tiny detail. Yeah, I love that. Phil Shea. Phil Shea, man. Well, as Jim and Michael are having this little scene in the parking lot, Holly would have said goodbye to everyone in the bullpen.
圣诞交换礼物派对上从奥斯卡那里得到的钥匙链。天呐，多棒、多微小的细节啊。对，我喜欢这个。菲尔·谢伊。菲尔·谢伊，真是个妙人。嗯，就在吉姆和迈克尔在停车场上演这场小戏时，霍莉本该跟办公区的每个人告别的。
It was a deleted scene. Jenna, I laughed so hard in this scene. I was really glad I'm way deep behind the partition. It's a series of people saying goodbye to her. But my absolute favorite was Oscar. Oscar Nunez is so good at like being the character that reigns on your parade. But he's just being reasonable, right?
这是一个被删减的片段。珍娜，在这场戏里我笑得太厉害了。我很庆幸我站在隔断后面很深的地方。这是一系列向她告别的人。但我绝对最喜欢的是奥斯卡。奥斯卡·努涅斯非常擅长扮演那种泼你冷水的人。但他只是在讲道理，对吧？
Yes. So he's like, you know, well, good luck. And she's like, well, I won't be that far. And then he goes on to say all of this and he just slowly, slowly reigns on her parade. Can you play it? We'll miss you. Oh, well, I'll be around. It's in a seven hour drive.
是的。所以他就像是，你知道，祝你好运。然后她说，嗯，我也不会去太远。接着他开始说所有这些话，然后就慢慢地、慢慢地泼她的冷水。你能播放一下吗？我们会想你的。哦，好吧，我会在附近的。这又不是七小时的车程。
Well, it's not that bad. But if I'm really jonesing to see you guys, I can always fly. I don't know if it'll be shorter to fly. You have to drive to Boston, right? That's an hour and a half. Get to an hour before the flight. I air up two and a half hours.
嗯，也没那么糟。但如果我真的很想见你们，我总是可以坐飞机。我不知道坐飞机是不是更短。你得开车去波士顿，对吧？那是一个半小时。在起飞前一个小时到达。我得提前两个半小时。
The flight to Philadelphia is an hour 15. It's another two and a half hour drive to Scranton. Assuming there's no traffic. Well, I just want to say goodbye. Okay. Okay. It made me laugh so hard. Yeah, I just wanted to say goodbye.
去费城的航班是一个小时十五分钟。到斯克兰顿还要开两个半小时的车。前提是没有交通堵塞。好吧，我只是想说再见。好吧。好吧。这让我笑得太厉害了。是的，我只是想说再见。
Right, right. But like, she's trying to make, like it's not going to be that bad. And he's like, well, I don't know about that. Like that person, Oscar was so good at being that person. So it keeps coming up in this episode that it is seven hours from Scranton to Nashua. Did you Google it?
对，对。但是，就像，她试图表现得，好像不会那么糟。而他却说，嗯，我可不这么认为。就像那个人，奥斯卡太擅长扮演那种角色了。所以在这一集里一直出现的一个说法是，从斯克兰顿到纳舒厄要开七个小时的车。你用谷歌查过吗？
It's not true. How far is it? Less than five. What? It's such a big difference. Why didn't anyone look that up in the right room? No, but it's only like four hours and 45 minutes. Are you kidding me?
这不是真的。到底有多远？不到五个小时。什么？差距这么大。为什么没有人在写剧本的房间里查一下？不，其实只要四小时四十五分钟。你在开玩笑吧？
I'm not kidding you. What rules were they taking? Are there new freeways? There were some like fan theories that it took them seven hours in that big truck. But that's not how we present it in this episode. We present it like, how are they ever gonna see each other? Like Holly says, even if you leave right after work, Michael,
我没开玩笑。他们走的是什么路线？有新开的高速公路吗？有一些粉丝理论说，他们开着那辆大卡车花了七个小时。但我们在这一集中并不是这样呈现的。我们呈现的方式是，他们怎么可能还能见到对方？就像霍莉说的，迈克尔，即使你一下班就出发，
you won't even get her till after midnight. And then we'll just have one day together. And you'll have to go back, but it's not true. They really scared themselves. I mean, at four hours, they're in the middle of nowhere. That's how we sell it. Exactly. Oh, wow.
你甚至要过午夜才能到。然后我们只有一天时间在一起。你就得回去了，但这根本不是真的。他们真的是把自己吓到了。我是说，开四小时车，他们就到了前不着村后不着店的地方。我们就是这么包装的。没错。哦，哇。
I know, so anyway, I just wanted to say that. I also did check the train schedule. For a reason I can't explain, it takes over 12 hours on the train. Maybe our writers check the train schedule. I don't know. Lot of stops though, I guess. My gosh.
我知道，总之，我只是想说这个。我还查了火车时刻表。由于某种无法解释的原因，坐火车居然要花十二个小时以上。也许我们的编剧查过火车时刻表。我不知道。不过我想大概有很多站吧。天哪。
Yeah, I know. Are you checking my work? You've got your phone out. She is checking my work. I'm not checking. What do you think? I don't know how to Google Scranton to Nashua? No, I'm very curious.
对，我知道。你在检查我的工作吗？你把手机拿出来了。她在检查我的工作。我没在检查。你觉得呢？难道我不会用谷歌查斯克兰顿到纳舒厄吗？不，我很好奇。
After all of my great information I've given you about rainbees. Can I tell you something right now? What? I'm doing it too. We're both Googling Scranton to Nashua. There it is, five hours. It's 311 miles.
在我给你讲了那么多关于雷恩比斯（Rainbees）的精彩信息之后。我现在能告诉你一件事吗？什么？我也在查。我们俩都在用谷歌查斯克兰顿到纳舒厄。这不，五个小时。有311英里。
Done. You know what's amazing is that a lot of people have written about this. I know, there's a whole Reddit thread. I know, I'm looking at the Reddit thread. See? Okay, well, this shouldn't have broken them up. It really should know.
搞定。你知道最神奇的是什么吗？很多人都写过这个。我知道，一整个红迪网（Reddit）的讨论串呢。我知道，我正在看红迪网的讨论串。看到了吗？好吧，这本来不该让他们分手的。真的不应该。
They should have picked a further branch. Okay, well, all right. Speaking of all of these driving scenes, should we get into it a little bit? We'll come back. Stuff is happening back at the office with Dwight and Andy but we'll get back to it. Should we do the driving?
他们本该选一个更远的分公司。好吧，那么。说到所有这些开车场景，我们要不要稍微深入聊聊？我们待会儿再回来。办公室里德怀特和安迪那边正发生着事，但我们待会儿会切回去。我们要不要聊聊开车的部分？
Let's do it. Let's get to the driving. Sam. Okay. I don't know, something all night long. Okay. Tom Cochran. According to James Apedia, they had two days
开始吧。切到开车的戏。萨姆。好吧。不知道，整晚都在播。好吧。汤姆·科克伦（Tom Cochran）。根据“詹姆斯百科（Jamesapedia）”，他们当时有两天
and a little more, like two days and a half to shoot the driving scenes. They shot mostly on the 118 freeway, a little bit on Burbank Boulevard. That's how we made it look like the East Coast. Some tidbits from Dave Rogers, they filmed this using lipstick cameras in the car and for the most part used a tow car.
多一点，大概两天半的时间来拍摄开车场景。他们主要是在118号高速公路上拍摄，伯班克大道上也拍了一点。这就是我们如何把它拍得像美国东海岸。戴夫·罗杰斯（Dave Rogers）的一些幕后花絮，他们在车里使用了唇膏大小的微型摄像机，大部分时候使用的是拖车。
So they had a big old truck that pulled the truck. Craig was not actually driving. So Dave told me that it was over 100 degrees. The days they were shooting. 104 is what they said in the commentary. And he, Randall Einhorn, RDP, Paul Feig and Veda had to sit in the back of the tow car. Under a tent.
所以他们有一辆老旧的大卡车拉着这辆卡车。克雷格其实并没有在开车。所以戴夫告诉我，气温超过了100华氏度。他们拍摄的那些天。他们在评论里说温度高达104华氏度。他、兰德尔·艾因霍恩（Randall Einhorn）、RDP、保罗·费格（Paul Feig）和维达（Veda）不得不坐在拖车的后部。在一个帐篷底下。
Yes, like a black box tent where they could see monitors showing them what was happening inside the car. They had little walkie-talkies so that they could talk to Amy and Steve and Craig. He said Paul Feig started removing layers of his suit because you know Paul used to wear like a three-piece suit every day.
对，就像一个黑色的大箱子帐篷，他们可以在里面看到显示器，了解车内发生的情况。他们有对讲机，可以跟艾米、史蒂夫和克雷格对话。他说保罗·费格开始脱掉身上的西装外套，因为你知道保罗以前每天都穿三件套西装。
Yeah, he said they were really jealous because Randall Einhorn wore the cooling vest. Yes, the cooling vest that Steve Carell had worn. Yeah, Veda said inside the tent with five monitors, all the heat was trapped in there. She said it felt like it was 200 degrees in there. Dave sent me some pictures. Oh no, were they like all melting?
对，他说他们真的很嫉妒，因为兰德尔·艾因霍恩穿了冷却背心。对，就是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔穿过的那种冷却背心。对，维达说帐篷里有五个显示器，所有的热气都被闷在里面了。她说里面感觉有200华氏度。戴夫给我发了一些照片。哦不，他们看起来都快融化了吗？
They were, they looked so hot. It was crazy. Yeah, so they are driving. They are singing the song over and over again. Over and over and then of course in the deleted scenes, you guys, they're pulling things out of that bag Michael packed and doing things.
是的，他们看起来热极了。太疯狂了。对，所以他们在开车。他们一遍又一遍地唱着那首歌。一遍又一遍，然后当然，在被删减的片段里，大家，他们从迈克尔收拾的那个包里掏出东西来做各种事。
And then one of the things they do is they just start doing like kissing push-ups. Oh my gosh, Daryl's face. They put their lips to each other and they're going one and two and three and four like that. It's so good and that didn't make it in but they're driving Daryl crazy. But then they start to realize this is far.
然后他们做的事情之一就是开始做接吻俯卧撑。哦天哪，达里尔的表情。他们把嘴唇贴向对方，嘴里数着一、二、三、四。太精彩了，虽然这个片段没有被剪进正片里，但他们把达里尔快逼疯了。不过接着他们开始意识到这路程可真远。
It's starting to hit them. Michael wants to save the day. He's like, stop right now. We're halfway. There's got to be an amazing bed and breakfast right here. Yeah, it's where we'll meet. It's going to be so cute. We'll meet in the middle.
他们开始有实感了。迈克尔想要挽救局面。他说，马上停下。我们已经走了一半了。这里肯定有一家很棒的住宿加早餐旅馆。对，这就是我们碰头的地方。一定会非常可爱。我们在中间碰头。
So they pull off the road. There's nothing. They're in the woods. Kyle, our location manager, shared this. He said when they went tech scouting, they found this location kind of like off the side of the road. Oh, this will be perfect.
于是他们把车开下了路。什么都没有。他们身处树林里。我们的外景经理凯尔分享了这件事，他说当他们进行技术勘景时，他们发现了这个离路边不远的地方。哦，这太完美了。
But then they found out another production was filming just a little ways down the way in the same area. He loves it. He didn't say who it was. But he said, normally this wouldn't concern us because we would film in our little nook. They would film in their nook and we'd be fine. He said, but then we found out
但后来他们发现另一个剧组正在不远处的同一区域拍摄。他很喜欢这个地方。他没说那是哪个剧组。但他说了，通常这不会影响我们，因为我们会呆在自己的小角落里。他们会在他们的角落里拍摄，相安无事。他说，但后来我们发现
they were filming a live band all day. And he said, we couldn't have a live band. So we had to find a whole new location and this spot was actually in Griffith Park. Oh, wow. Yeah. It's so funny when you said another show was filming there. I assumed it was like a murder show or 24 or something.
他们一整天都在拍一支现场乐队。他说，我们不能有现场乐队。所以我们不得不重新找一个全新的外景地，而这个地方实际上是在格里菲斯公园（Griffith Park）。哦，哇。是的。当你提到另一个剧组在那里拍摄时，我觉得太搞笑了。我以为是个凶杀剧或者《24小时》之类。
Right. Because who else needs just like to be out in the weird woods? Maybe a teen rom-com. I guess so with a live band. Right. Here's another little thing I caught, Jenna. At 9 minutes, 53 seconds, while Michael and Holly are having this heart-to-heart in the car,
对啊。因为谁会没事跑到奇怪的树林里去呢？也许是一部青少年浪漫喜剧吧。我想是的，还有现场乐队。没错。珍娜，我还抓到了一个小细节。在9分53秒时，当迈克尔和霍莉在车里进行这场知心谈话时，
Darrell's getting gas, right? Yeah. Did you see what the front license plate said? No. It just says Rock 107. The license plate on the truck? Yes. On the front of the truck says Rock 107, a radio station.
达里尔正在加油，对吧？对。你看到前车牌写的是什么了吗？没有。上面只写着“摇滚107（Rock 107）”。卡车车牌吗？对。卡车正面写着“摇滚107”，一个广播电台。
Is there a Rock 107 in Scranton? Yes. Oh, my gosh. It plays classic rock. Of course it does, Sam. Rock 107, although I suppose, actually, these are all coming off of Michael's mixed CD that he made for the trip.
斯克兰顿有“摇滚107”吗？有的。哦，天哪。它播放经典摇滚。理所当然，萨姆。“摇滚107”，不过我想，其实这些歌都来自迈克尔为这次旅行制作的混合磁带。
Life is a highway. Now, we all know I made. You're Scranton mixed CD. Sounds of Scranton. I would have put this on there because it was just a mix of classic rock. You know who would have appreciated my CD? Michael Scott.
《生活是一条高速公路（Life Is a Highway）》。现在，我们都知道我做了。你的斯克兰顿混合磁带。斯克兰顿之声。我也会把这首歌放进去，因为它只是一组合集经典摇滚。你知道谁会欣赏我的磁带吗？迈克尔·斯科特。
Michael Scott. Jennifer Fisher and Michael Scott. Yes. Hanging out. So while Darrell is getting gas, Michael says that he's dated four women in the last 10 years, and Holly surpasses them all. Well, Veda, our script, he shared
迈克尔·斯科特。詹妮弗·费舍尔（Jennifer Fisher）和迈克尔·斯科特。是的。一起闲逛。所以当达里尔在加油时，迈克尔说他在过去的10年里约会过四个女人，而霍莉超越了所有这些人。好吧，维达，我们的剧本，他分享说
that the last 10 years was an improv from Steve. Oh. It made it so much better, I have to say. I know. I know. Everything about that, when she thinks he means four people in the last year, and he says in the last 10 years,
“过去的10年”是史蒂夫的即兴发挥。哦。不得不说，这让效果好太多了。我知道。我知道。关于这一段的一切，当她以为他指的是过去一年里有四个人，而他说是在过去10年里时，
kind of at the same time, I was like, oh, Michael. I know. I love you so much, Michael. And they were ad-libbing right there. Aw. All of it really breaks my heart, and because as they're getting closer, you can really see Holly shutting down.
几乎在同一时间，我就想，哦，迈克尔。我知道。迈克尔，我太爱你了。他们当时就在那里即兴发挥。噢。这一切真的让我心碎，因为随着他们越来越接近目的地，你能明显看到霍莉开始崩溃。
Oh, she starts crying while the song is playing. And Amy Ryan crushed that. I know. That was so good. Well, Dave talked about this. He said he really wanted a three-shot. He wanted to see Michael and Holly having this moment. Michael begging Holly, no, don't do this.
哦，歌声响起时她开始哭了。艾米·瑞安（Amy Ryan）把这个角色演绝了。我知道。太精彩了。好吧，戴夫谈到了这一点。他说他真的很想要一个三人镜头。他想看到迈克尔和霍莉经历这个时刻。迈克尔恳求霍莉，不，别这么做。
We don't need to break up. And Daryl just making a random phone call. Like, just he need to talk to anyone, someone. Yes. And he wanted to see all of that at the same time. I mean, it's not an easy shot, but Dave was like, no, no, no. I want to see all three of them. You had to see all three of them.
我们不需要分手。而达里尔只是在打一个随意的电话。就好像，他只是需要跟任何人、随便什么人说话。对。他想同时看到这一切。我是说，这可不是个容易的镜头，但戴夫态度坚决，不，不，不。我想同时看到他们三个。你必须同时看到他们三个。
Yeah. It only works that way. Because he said it's like two scenes happening at the same time. Well, maybe we should take a break from the car because we need to cover what's happening back at the office. Oh, yeah. Dwight is applying for Cornell, you guys.
对。只能这样拍才行。因为他说这就像两场戏在同时发生。好吧，也许我们该从车里的戏暂停一下，因为我们需要聊聊办公室里正在发生的事。哦，对。德怀特在申请康奈尔大学呢，大家。
Oh, yeah. And also, Pam's about to have lunch with Jim's brothers. There's a lot to still talk about. The pranksters. We'll be right back. MUSIC Dwight arrives to work. He is wearing a Cornell sweatshirt over his mustard
哦，对了。还有，潘快要和吉姆的兄弟们吃午饭了。还有很多事要聊。恶作剧达人们。我们马上回来。音乐德怀特来到公司上班。他在芥末黄衬衫外面套了一件康奈尔大学的运动衫。
shirt. Yeah. You want to know why he's wearing that sweatshirt? Because he's applying to Cornell. That's right. Yes. I mean, did he know how to go after Andy or what? What does Andy covet, that Cornell diploma?
对。你们想知道他为什么要穿那件运动衫吗？因为他在申请康奈尔大学。没错。是的。我是说，他可真知道怎么戳安迪的痛处，对吧？安迪最垂涎的是什么，不就是那张康奈尔大学的文凭吗？
My favorite thing is when you see Andy fuming in the back of Dwight's talking head. When he's bobbing his chair back and forth. So good. So good. I have a little Phil Props tidbit about this talking head. Dwight is holding up a coffee mug that also says Cornell. Yeah.
我最喜欢的部分，就是你在德怀特的“单人访谈”背景里看到安迪气得火冒三丈。当他的椅子前后摇晃的时候。太精彩了。太棒了。关于这个访谈，我有一个关于菲尔·普罗普斯（Phil Props）的小花絮。德怀特手里拿著一个也印着康奈尔字样的咖啡杯。对。
Well, this was sort of a last minute pitch from Dave. He really wanted to pump up the Cornell merch. OK. So he was like, what if he's holding something? They made that mug in two hours. What? Our props department. Oh, my gosh.
好吧，这算是戴夫临时起意的一个点子。他真的很想多露出一些康奈尔大学的周边商品。好吧。所以他就说，如果他手里拿点什么东西会怎么样？他们两个小时就做出了那个杯子。什么？我们的道具部门。哦，天哪。
Yeah. So that he could have it in this talking head. You know, I've seen that happen on set sometimes, where there'll be an actor and they're supposed to carry a briefcase, for example. And the props team will come up during the rehearsal of the scene on the day. We're lighting.
对。这样他就能在访谈里拿着用。你知道，我有几次在片场看到过这种情况，比如演员原本被要求拿一个公文包。然后道具团队就会在当天的场景排练期间跑过来。当时我们正在打光。
We're getting ready to shoot. And they show the actor three briefcase options. And then the actor says, oh, no, no. I imagined it would be like a distressed leather. Maybe it was my father's. They could pass down to me. And the props person, you just see them just having a heart attack, basically.
准备拍摄。然后他们向演员展示了三款公文包供选择。接着演员就会说，哦，不，不。我想象中它应该是一种做旧皮革质感的。也许是我父亲传下来的那种。然后道具人员，你就能看出他们基本上要心脏病发了。
And I feel like the actor and director's producers, the writer of the episode, they might all have a thought last minute like that. On what this prop should look like. And the props person is like, always. Without fail, they're always like, oh, yeah, yeah, OK. No problem. We'll get that.
我觉得演员、导演、制片人、剧集编剧，他们所有人可能都会在最后一刻有这样的想法。关于这个道具应该长什么样。而道具人员总是毫无例外地会说，哦，没问题，没问题，好吧。没问题。我们去弄。
And then I know that they take a van to some warehouse. And they go through a giant shelf of all these briefcases to try to find the thing that the actor talked about. Or they run across the parking lot. Yeah. And try to get something printed in the moment. I have such a memory of Phil running across the parking lot. My only memories of Phil are that he is running.
然后我知道他们会开着一辆面包车去某个仓库。他们会在成千上万个公文包的巨型货架中翻找，试图找到演员口中描述的那种东西。或者他们会一路小跑穿过停车场。对。并试图当场打印出某种东西。我对菲尔跑过停车场有很深的记忆。我对菲尔唯一的记忆就是他在奔跑。
Running or fast walking and talking. Hey, Phil, hey, how's it going? No, I've just got to make a coffee mug. I'm going to print out a thing. And we're going to get that. We're going to get that made. Yep. Can't wait.
要么在跑，要么在快走并说话。嘿，菲尔，嘿，最近怎么样？不，我得去做个咖啡杯。我要打印个东西。我们这就去搞定。我们马上把它做出来。行。迫不及待了。
Yeah. Props are amazing. Props, department, kick and butt. Well, throughout all of this, Dwight is just winding Andy up. They've got that scene in the kitchen. Dwight has clearly done his research. Oh, yeah. After that scene in the kitchen, there's
对。道具太棒了。道具部门，干得漂亮。好吧，在这一切过程中，德怀特一直在激怒安迪。他们在厨房里有场对手戏。德怀特显然做足了功课。哦，对。厨房那场戏之后，还有
a deleted scene of Andy in the parking lot going off to his dad. Like, I died, dad. I'm going to get him. He's like so mad. One of my favorite scenes is the one with Dwight at his desk where he's got all this merch. There's like a pendant hanging from the ceiling. And then he reaches into his drawer
一段被删减的戏，是安迪在停车场气急败坏地向他老爸抱怨。就像，气死我了，爸。我一定要整他。他气得要命。我最喜欢的场景之一，就是德怀特坐在办公桌前，周围全是各种周边商品的那场戏。天花板上还挂着一面三角旗。然后他把手伸进抽屉里，
and he gets out a Cornell bobblehead. Yeah. And Andy loses it. He's like, that's big red bear. Well, I has Phil Shea if that was a real Cornell bobblehead or if we had to make it. And he said it was real throughout all these years of the show because Andy had gone to school at Cornell.
拿出一个康奈尔大学的摇头娃娃。对。然后安迪彻底失控了。他说，那是大红熊（Big Red Bear）。好吧，我问过菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea），那是真正的康奈尔摇头娃娃，还是我们自己做的。他说，在剧集播出的这么多年里，它是真的，因为安迪曾在康奈尔大学上过学。
He made contacts at the school, particularly the Cornell bookstore. And that is where he got the bobblehead. He said, Claudia, Sandra, Peggy, and Patricia are the ladies at Cornell that would always help him out whenever we had a storyline that required some Cornell merch. There's going to be a really good one coming up. And I can't wait to share it in a future episode. Thank you, ladies.
他在学校建立了一些人脉，尤其是康奈尔大学书店。他就是从那里弄到了这个摇头娃娃。他说，克劳迪娅、桑德拉、佩姬和帕特里夏是康奈尔大学的几位女士，每当我们的剧情需要一些康奈尔的周边商品时，她们总是会给予帮助。接下来会有一个非常精彩的情节。我迫不及待想在以后的节目中分享它。谢谢你们，女士们。
I love that Phil had all his people. He had all his people everywhere. Oh, yeah. Well, I have a little thing to share about that Cornell bobblehead as well. So it was not the first choice. What was the first choice? So to ratchet Andy up, Dwight was going to have his cell phone
我喜欢菲尔拥有他自己的“人脉网”。他到处都有人脉。哦，对。好吧，关于那个康奈尔摇头娃娃，我也有个小八卦要分享。其实它并不是最初的第一选择。最初的选择是什么？为了进一步刺激安迪，德怀特原本打算让他的手机
ringtone be the Cornell fight song. Ooh, that's a good idea. Yeah. But then when they heard it, it just didn't quite work in the moment. It was just like too much setup. And so they felt like the bobblehead was just like this quick, like boom, I now have the Cornell merch on my desk. Well, I like the personal connection to Angela and the bobbleheads as well.
铃声变成康奈尔大学的校歌。哦，这主意不错。对。但当他们听到那个铃声时，觉得在当时的情境下不太搭。铺垫的成分有点太多了。所以他们觉得摇头娃娃的效果更好，就像是一种快速的视觉冲击：看，我的桌上现在有康奈尔的周边了。不过我也很喜欢它和安吉拉以及摇头娃娃之间的某种个人情感联结。
Side by side. Yes. So I like that choice for that reason. Well, it almost was Give My Regards to Davey, which is the Cornell fight song playing on Dwight's cell phone. You know the scene where Andy confronts Dwight outside of the bathroom? Mm-hmm. And Dwight starts asking Andy what acapella group he should join?
并排摆放。是的。所以出于这个原因，我很喜欢这个选择。好吧，原本差一点就变成了把《向戴维致敬》（Give My Regards to Davey）——也就是康奈尔的校歌——作为德怀特的手机铃声播放。你知道安迪在洗手间外面质问德怀特的那个场景吗？嗯嗯。然后德怀特开始问安迪他该加入哪个无伴奏合唱团？
Yeah. At Cornell. The Harmoniacs are the Doremigos? Yes. I looked it up. According to the Cornell acapella advisory council, there is a Cornell acapella advisory council. Amazing.
对。在康奈尔。是 Harmoniacs 还是 Doremigos？是的。我查过了。根据康奈尔无伴奏合唱咨询委员会的说法，还真有个康奈尔无伴奏合唱咨询委员会。太神奇了。
There are not any current acapella groups with those names, but I'm not sure about when we filmed. Aca what? Aca, let me tell you. Veda said that Rain was improvising quite a bit in this moment. Oh, some was scripted, and then he just started going off. I see. Yes.
现在没有任何无伴奏合唱团叫那些名字，但我不确定我们拍摄当时是不是这样。无伴奏什么？无伴奏，我跟你说。维达说雷恩在拍摄这一段时进行了大量的即兴发挥。哦，有些是剧本写好的，然后他自己就开始自由发挥了。原来如此。是的。
And also, Anthony shared that he pitched that Stanley should be the first person to come out of the bathroom to kind of throw Andy off because Andy's so ready. And then Stanley comes out and he's like, and then he has to get his energy back up for Dwight. I love that little moment. Great detail. All of this is going to lead to a delicious scene in the conference room
而且，安东尼还透露，他建议让斯坦利第一个从洗手间走出来，以此来打乱安迪的节奏，因为安迪当时已经蓄势待发了。然后斯坦利走出来，说了句“”，接着他又得重新聚起气势来对付德怀特。我好喜欢这个小细节。细节满分。所有这一切都将引向会议室里的一场好戏，
because Andy informs Dwight, guess who is conducting your interview? He's contacted Cornell, and he's going to do the interview. Yeah. And Dwight's like, bring it on. I love this conference room scene so much. I love it so much. Dave shared that this conference room scene between Dwight and Andy was his first day of filming.
因为安迪通知德怀特，猜猜是谁来对你进行面试？他联系了康奈尔大学，他要亲自来主持面试。对。然后德怀特说，放马过来吧。我太喜欢会议室这场戏了。我太喜欢了。戴夫分享说，德怀特和安迪在会议室里的这场戏是他第一天拍摄的内容。
What? Yes, and he loved that because it was so contained, right? Oh my gosh, yes. Right? And he said it was about a 10 to 11 page scene. That's a huge scene. Yes, a lot of people asked, was this scripted or improvised? It was almost all scripted.
什么？是的，而且他很喜欢这样，因为场景非常局促，对吧？哦天哪，没错。对吧？他说这大概是一场10到11页剧本的戏。这可真是一场大戏。对，很多人问，这是按剧本演的还是即兴发挥的？几乎全是按照剧本演的。
It was almost all scripted, but Veda said that they did let Rain and Ed really play around, especially with the role model name pitches. And these guys kept laughing. They were breaking so hard in the scene. In the end, Dwight says his role models are Dane Cook, Jack Bauer, and Eli Whitney, but in the script, they're different. And there's many takes of these names being different. But there was one big part of this scene that was improvised.
几乎全是按剧本演的，但维达说他们确实让雷恩和爱德尽情发挥了，特别是列举那些偶像名字的时候。这俩人笑得不行。他们在拍摄时笑场得太厉害了。最后，德怀特说他的偶像分别是戴恩·库克（Dane Cook）、杰克·鲍尔（Jack Bauer）和埃里伊·惠特尼（Eli Whitney），但在剧本里，他们的名字是不一样的。他们试拍了好几个不同名字的版本。不过这场戏里有一个重大的部分是即兴发挥的。
And Anthony talks about it. It's so good. That scene that we had in the conference room where they were, the double interview, as it were, that was always like, had always been in there as a fun scene for the two of them to square off at the end of that episode. I do remember there was a moment where it was either Rain or Ed started pulling the table.
安东尼谈到了这一点。太棒了。我们在会议室里拍的那场戏，也就是那场双人面试，一直以来都被设定为一处好玩的桥段，让他们俩在这一集的结尾处一决高我。我确实记得有那么一个时刻，不管是雷恩还是爱德，开始去拉扯那张桌子。
And I was just like, ugh, we've got to do that more. So I talked to Dave Rogers, who was directing his first episode of The Office. And he's directed 1,000 things since because he's freaking amazing. I remember talking to him. They've got to just let him play with that table, let him pull it back and forth, let him struggle with that
当时我就想，呃，我们得让这个动作更多一点。所以我跟戴夫·罗杰斯聊了聊，这是他第一次执导《办公室》的剧集。从那以后他已经导演了一千部作品，因为他简直太棒了。我记得当时跟他谈过。他们必须得让他和那张桌子较劲，让他把它拉来拉去，让他跟它搏斗，
and see what happens. And I think that was the only take I think we did of that, where Rain just pulls it all the way to the wall. And thanks him for coming. Just that whole, those characters are all about conflict, all about power shifts. And that whole dynamic just felt like the right place to end up with those characters.
看看会发生什么。我想这大概是我们拍的唯一一个那样的镜头，雷恩直接把桌子一路拉到了墙边。然后还谢谢安迪大驾光临。整段戏，这两个角色就是为了冲突而生，全都是关于权力的更迭。整个动态感觉就是给这两个角色做收尾的绝佳去处。
And so that was a nice little bit of improv that we got to enhance on the day. I feel like Dave must have been so excited after this first shoot day to get that table tugging moment, to get this whole scene. These guys are so good in it. He had to have been fired up. You would think so.
所以这是我们在拍摄当天即兴创作的一个非常精彩的小亮点。我感觉戴夫在经历了这个第一天的拍摄，捕捉到了拔河般的桌子互动以及整场戏之后，一定兴奋极了。他肯定热血沸腾了。你可以这么认为。
I mean, the biggest stuff was ahead of him, but at least he had that first day in the conference room. Well, you know, it's interesting Dave shared with me, the last thing we shot for this episode was the Halloween cold open. That was the last day of shooting. Oh, wow. Yeah, he said we needed time to get all those costumes
我是说，更重头的大戏还在后头，但至少他拥有了会议室里的那个第一天。好吧，你知道的，戴夫跟我分享了一个有趣的事，我们为这一集拍摄的最后一个镜头是万圣节的开场白。那是拍摄的最后一天。哦，哇。对，他说我们需要时间来搞定所有的服装
and everything organized. Yeah. Should we talk about what's going on with Jim and Pam during all of this now? Yes. So we know that they're gonna have lunch with Jim's brothers, but what we find out is that Pam gets to the restaurant early. Yeah.
和一切筹备工作。好吧，我们现在该聊聊吉姆和潘在这期间都在做什么了吗？好的。所以我们知道他们要和吉姆的兄弟们共进午餐，但我们发现的是潘很早就到了餐厅。对。
She wants to do a prank. Because she wants them to like her. Yeah. She's like gonna be the fun sister-in-law. Jenna, do you have a guest star breakdown? You know I do. Pete Halpert was played by Tug Coker. And Tom Halpert was played by Blake Robbins.
她想搞个恶作剧。因为她想让他们喜欢她。对。她打算扮演那个有趣的嫂子。珍娜，你有客串演员的演员表详细资料吗？你懂的，我当然有。皮特·哈尔珀特（Pete Halpert）由塔格·科克尔（Tug Coker）饰演。汤姆·哈尔珀特（Tom Halpert）由布莱克·罗宾斯（Blake Robbins）饰演。
They were super tall. Very tall. There's the reason for that. John Krasinski has two very tall brothers in real life, and they thought this would be a fun nod to his family. Yeah. I was able to get in touch with Tug, by the way. And oh, my gosh.
他们个子超级高。非常高。这背后是有原因的。约翰·卡拉辛斯基在现实生活中有两个非常高的兄弟，他们觉得这可以作为对他家人的一个有趣致敬。对。顺便说一句，我联系上了塔格。哦，天哪。
I could not love this guy more. I mean, we had such a fun time shooting together, and I had so much fun reminiscing with him about this. He told me that the audition notice for this episode, it said it was looking for actors who were six foot one or taller, preferably with brown hair, but it did not reveal that you would be playing Jim Halpert's brother.
我简直不能更喜欢这家伙了。我是说，我们一起拍摄时度过了一段非常快乐的时光，我和他一起回忆这段经历时也感到无比开心。他告诉我，这一集的试镜通知上写着，它在寻找身高六尺一寸或以上、最好有棕色头发的演员，但并没有透露你将扮演吉姆·哈尔珀特的兄弟。
And when he got to the audition, he said, first of all, he's six foot five, and when he got to the audition, Alison Jones said, you look like you could play John Krasinski's brother. That's what she said, and he was like, oh, I'm going to be playing a helper. Yeah. That was his first clue.
当他去试镜时，他说，首先，他身高六尺五寸，而当他到达试镜现场时，艾莉森·琼斯（Alison Jones）说：“你看上去很适合演约翰·卡拉辛斯基的兄弟。”她就是这么说的，然后他就想，哦，我要演一个哈尔珀特了。对。那是他的第一个线索。
He read with Alison's associate, Ben Harris, and the next day, he got a call that he'd gotten the part. Well, I definitely felt like these guys looked like they could be John's brothers. And you know John's brothers in real life are super tall. They're like 6' 8", or something. They're like the tallest family. Isn't John the short one?
他和艾莉森的助手本·哈里斯（Ben Harris）对过戏，第二天，他就接到电话说他得到了这个角色。好吧，我确实觉得这些家伙看起来很像是约翰的兄弟。而且你知道约翰现实生活中的兄弟个子也超高。他们好像有6尺8寸左右，或者差不多。他们家就像是最高的一家人。难道约翰不是个矮个子吗？
Yes. And John is 6' 3". Yeah, and he's the shorty. That is so crazy. Well, Tug said, here's the thing that happens when you're a really tall actor. You usually have to bring your own clothes. Listen, Tug.
是的。而约翰身高6尺3寸。对，他是那个小矮个。太疯狂了。好吧，塔格说，事情是这样的，当一个身高极高的演员时，你通常得自己带衣服来。听着，塔格。
That's what happens when you're a really short actor, too. Angela can relate. He said that is his own suit, and those are his own shoes. I believe it. He's pretty sure that Blake wore his own clothes in the scene as well. So you know this first scene at the restaurant, Angela, where Pam has met them early, and she's pitching her idea
当你个子特别矮的时候，这也是不可避免的。安吉拉对此深有同感。他说那是他自己的西装，穿的也是他自己的鞋子。我信。他挺确信布莱克在戏里穿的也是他自己的衣服。所以你知道餐厅里的这场戏，安吉拉，潘提前到了那里，她正在推销她关于
for what the prank could be. She says her ring, she put it in her little apron, she left it, she's going to throw another girl under the bus. This whole drama, she lost her engagement ring. And they're like, oh, we have a better idea. Their idea is that they're going to dog Pam about her career choice as an artist. Yeah, and they said, let's do the same thing we did to Jim's
恶作剧应该怎么搞的点子。她说她的戒指，她把它放在自己的小围裙里，弄丢了，她打算把另一个女孩推出来当替罪羊。这一整出戏剧冲突，她弄丢了订婚戒指。而他们却说，哦，我们有个更好的主意。他们的想法是，他们要疯狂贬低潘作为艺术家的职业选择。对，而且他们说，咱们就用当年对付吉姆高中女朋友的那招。
girlfriend in high school. What the heck, guys? What is your pattern here? Oh, our bit is we make the girls that Jim's dating feel crappy about themselves. I know. What the heck? I know.
搞什么鬼，兄弟们？你们的套路怎么总是这样？哦，我们的保留节目就是让吉姆正在交往的女朋友自我感觉糟糕透顶。我知道。搞什么鬼？我知道。
They said in the DVD commentary that they wanted Jim's brothers to be bad at pranking. Like, they're like the less sophisticated prankers of the family. Jim is better at pranking. They're kind of lame at it. So most of this stuff was scripted in the restaurant. We did not have a lot of time, actually, to play around.
他们在DVD评论里说过，他们希望吉姆的兄弟们不擅长搞恶作剧。就好像他们是家族里水平比较逊的恶作剧者。吉姆比他们擅长恶作剧。他们的把戏有点逊。所以餐厅里的这些内容大部分都是照着剧本拍的。其实我们没有太多时间来自由发挥。
But Tug reminded me that we did improvise the very end of this scene. He said, Jenna, I'm pretty sure you improvised that line. So not the ring thing, then. And then the two of them are like, no, no, no, no. This is better. This is better. And I checked the script and he's right.
但塔格提醒我，这场戏的最末尾部分确实是我们即兴发挥的。他说，珍娜，我很确信那句台词是你即兴发挥的。所以不是戒指那件事，然后他们俩就说，不，不，不，不。这样更好。这样更好。我查了剧本，他是对的。
The scene had actually been meant to end sooner. That sounds like you in real life, by the way. That sounds like something you would say. Maybe so. I feel like we've ordered lunch together. And I've gone back and forth about an appetizer. And you've said, so not the dip, then. We're not doing the dip.
这场戏原本应该更早结束的。顺便说一句，听上去很符合你的现实风格。听上去就像你会说的话。也许吧。我觉得我们一起点过午餐。而且我为了前菜纠结来纠结去。然后你会说，所以不是蘸酱，对吧？我们不点那个蘸酱了。
Just to clarify. Well, Dave shared that you guys filmed this restaurant scene the day after Labor Day, Tuesday in September. I thought that was a fun little detail to know. And Kyle, the Locations Manager, said that this restaurant was called E3rd. And it was on the east side of downtown LA. They were really trying to get this area to double as Brooklyn,
澄清一下。好吧，戴夫分享说，你们拍这场餐厅戏是在劳动节的第二天，也就是九月份的一个星期我觉得这是一个很好玩的小细节。而且外景经理凯尔说，这家餐厅名叫 E3rd。它位于洛杉矶市中心的东区。他们当时真的很努力想让这个地区看起来像布鲁克林，
where Pam was attending prep. I think they did a good job. Well, the restaurant was a steakhouse. And in the next scene where you see that we're eating, after Jim has arrived, we got to just pick off the menu. Oh, so you're really eating the restaurant food? Yeah. Oh, that's so lucky.
也就是潘当时上预科的地方。我觉得他们做得挺好。好吧，这家餐厅是一家牛排馆。而在下一场你们看到我们在吃东西的戏里，吉姆到了之后，我们可以直接从菜单上点菜。哦，所以你们真的是在吃餐厅里的食物？对。哦，那太幸运了。
I know. Oh, that's cool. Well, Tug said he remembers it very clearly because it was the very first time he had to eat in a scene. And when they gave him the menu, he thought his character would order steak at a steakhouse. And that John Krasinski said, oh, dude, you're going to regret that choice.
我知道。哦，太酷了。好吧，塔格说他对此记忆犹新，因为这是他第一次必须在戏里吃东西。当他们把菜单交给他时，他想当然地认为自己的角色在牛排馆里应该点牛排。而约翰·卡拉辛斯基说，哦，老兄，你一会儿准会后悔这个选择的。
You're going to be eating cold steak for several hours. And Tug was like, what do you mean I'm going to eat steak? And that's what my character would eat. And he said, John ordered a salad and a little protein on the side. And that's what I ordered as well. Well, Tug said that his concern about ordering a salad was that he didn't want any food to fall on him
你得吃好几个小时的冷牛排。塔格当时就想，什么叫我吃牛排会后悔？我的角色就该吃这个。然后他说，约翰点了一份沙拉，外加一点蛋白质补充。于是我也点了那个。好吧，塔格说他担心点沙拉的原因是，他不想在拍戏时让食物掉到自己身上。
during the scene. He was like, this is the first time I'm eating and acting. I think steak, I can get it on the fork. I can get it in my mouth. Well, steak is definitely easier to eat than salad. Well, Tug pointed out to me. And I didn't notice it the first time I watched it. But he said it's burned in his brain
他当时想，这是我第一次一边吃东西一边演戏。我想牛排的话，我可以把它叉起来。我可以把它放进嘴里。好吧，牛排确实比沙拉好对付。好吧，塔格向我指出了一点。我第一次看的时候并没有注意到。但他说这件事烙印在他的脑海里，
because this is the scene that was on his acting reel for years and years. So at 12 minutes, 25 seconds, John is struggling with this bite of salad. You can see it. I saw that too. He's having a very hard time getting this piece of lettuce in his mouth.
因为这是他多年来演艺履历集锦里一直用的片段。所以在12分25秒时，约翰正在艰难地吃着这一口沙拉。你能看出来的。我也看到了。他费了好大劲才把这片生菜送进嘴里。
And then, if you watch closely, one leaf misses his mouth and falls into his lap, which was exactly Tug's fear that if Tug had been eating salad, he would have missed his mouth. He was then glad he had ordered that steak and had to eat it for hours. John, as I rewatched that, I thought, that's a really big, aggressive bite of lettuce.
然后，如果你仔细看，有一片生菜叶子错过了他的嘴，掉到了他的大腿上，这正是塔格一开始最担心的——如果当时是塔格在吃沙拉，他也会错过自己的嘴。他当时庆幸自己点了牛排，虽然得吃上好几个小时。约翰，当我重看那一幕时，我想，这真是一大口、充满攻击性的生菜啊。
He really went for it. He did. Sometimes when you're eating salad in a scene, you don't realize what you've got on the fork, and then you just have to commit to it. And that was on Tug's reel, that he watched it over and over. Over and over again, he watched that piece of lettuce fall. So you know their dinner starts out pretty sweet, right?
他是真的下狠口去咬了。他确实是。有时候你在戏里吃沙拉时，你根本意识不到叉子上叉了多少东西，然后你只能硬着头皮把它吃下去。而那一幕就出现在塔格的视频集锦里，他一遍又一遍地看着。他一遍又一遍地看着那片生菜叶子掉落。所以你知道他们的晚餐开始时挺温馨的，对吧？
Jim is holding up a photo of his niece, right? Yeah. So you feel like this is going to be nice. It's pre-prank. The prank hasn't started yet. Prank hasn't started yet. The photo that John is holding up is our set medic, Patrice King's daughter.
吉姆举着一张他侄女的照片，对吧？对。所以你会觉得这氛围会很不错。这是恶作剧之前。恶作剧还没开始呢。恶作剧还没开始。约翰举着的那张照片，其实是我们的剧组医疗人员帕特里斯·金（Patrice King）的女儿。
Aw. Yeah, Phil shared that. Phil would do that, you guys. This scene also has the moment where all of us, at the end of the scene, give a look to camera. And it's such a cool moment. Tug said he remembers Dave Roger giving him the direction to check in with the camera throughout the scene.
噢。是的，菲尔分享了这一点。菲尔绝对会干这种事的，大家。这场戏里还有一个时刻，我们在戏的结尾处全员看向了镜头。那是一个非常酷的时刻。塔格说他记得戴夫·罗杰斯给他的导演指导就是，在整场戏中不断跟镜头进行眼神互动。
And this was like so crazy to him, because he'd never been in a project where you were allowed to look down the lens like that. But I love this moment. I love the look that he gives the camera. And you just go around the table, and we all give this little look to camera about this prank that is not going well.
这对他来说太疯狂了，因为他从没参与过允许你直视镜头的项目。但我好喜欢这个时刻。我好喜欢他看向镜头的那个表情。然后你沿着桌子看过去，我们每个人都针对这个进展不顺的恶作剧，齐齐向镜头投去了这样一个小眼神。
Not going well. Dave talked about it a little bit. He said he wanted the brothers to look to camera to just give that subtle hint that their manualisms were similar to Jim, that they would check in like that. At eight minutes, 33 seconds, Pete gives a solo look to camera. And at 12 minutes, 31 seconds,
进展不顺。戴夫稍微谈了谈这一点。他说他希望兄弟俩看镜头，只是为了给出这样一个微妙的暗示：他们的习惯动作和吉姆很像，他们也会这样跟镜头互动。在8分33秒时，皮特独自看了一次镜头。而在12分31秒时，
Tom gives a Jim kind of shrug to camera. I loved that one. I thought that was so good. Well, as this prank continues, it is really getting under Pam's skin. Like she is getting very flustered. I think particularly when he suggests that she pay the bill by drawing on the napkin.
汤姆对镜头做了一个吉姆式的耸肩。我很喜欢那个镜头。我觉得太棒了。好吧，随着这个恶作剧的继续，它真的让潘有点破防了。她开始变得非常慌乱。尤其是当他建议她通过在餐巾纸上画画来付账单时，我想她肯定是破防了。
Oh, Jenna, if you need a boost, listen to the DVD commentary, because Veda said she was so impressed with your performance. Aw. She said, you know, the way this was scripted is tough, because Pam has to wanna be on board to be pranked, but then also start clocking like,
哦，珍娜，如果你需要一点信心加持，去听听DVD评论音轨，因为维达说她对你的表演印象深刻。噢。她说，你知道，这样写剧本其实挺难的，因为潘既想要配合大家的恶作剧，但同时又开始察觉到：
hey, that's kind of a dig. Okay, you're kind of going too far. And she said, Jenna did such an amazing job. It was really sweet. Veda was showing you some love. That's really sweet. Well, it was kind of a fine line because everything that Veda said,
嘿，这话听着有点刺耳。好吧，你们有点过分了。她说，珍娜演得太棒了。真的非常贴心。维达这是在表达对你的喜爱呢。真是太暖心了。好吧，这其实是一条微妙的界限，因为维达所说的一切，
part of the storyline was also meant to further Pam's insecurity about the idea of being an artist. Oh. And, you know, because this is something that she wants, but Pam is not a person with a lot of certainty all the time. And this was supposed to play on that. It was a lot for Pam to go to art school. It really was.
剧情的一部分也是为了加深潘对自己作为艺术家的身份的不安全感。哦。而且，你知道，因为这是她梦寐以求的事情，但潘并不是一个随时都充满自信的人。这段剧情本意就是利用这一点。潘去读艺术学校，其实压力真的很大。确实如此。
Yeah. And so this is meant to kind of discourage her momentum. Aw, that makes me sad. Yeah. I know, I know. I have to say, it was so nice reconnecting with Tug about these scenes. You know, he said he's still in touch with Blake.
是的。所以这旨在消磨她的干劲。噢，这让我听了有点难过。对，我知道，我知道。我得说，能和塔格重新建立联系并聊起这些场景，真的太美妙了。你知道，他说他现在还跟布莱克保持着联系。
He still gets recognized for having been on the show. Something he told me that I thought was really special was that the day this episode aired, Dave Rogers called him personally, complimented his performance, and told him, hey, I wanted you to know that the bulk of the brother's scenes made it into the episode.
他至今还会因为出演过这部剧而被认出来。他告诉我的一件事我觉得特别特别，那就是这一集播出的那天，戴夫·罗杰斯亲自打电话给他，称赞了他的表演，并告诉他：“嘿，我想让你知道，兄弟俩的大部分戏份都剪进正片里了。”
And so when you see it tonight, it's there. That is so nice. No one does that. That was so nice of Dave. No one does that. And Tug said, you know, I'd done a ton of guest roles, and sometimes you tell your whole family to watch it and they watch it,
“所以你今晚看的时候，它就在里面。”太暖心了。没人会这么做。戴夫太好了。根本没人会这么做。塔格说，你知道，我演过一大堆客串角色，有时候你让全家人都去看，他们也看了，
and your whole part has been reduced to one line. All the time. He said, so he was so excited. He called his friends and family, and he was like, yes, yes, watch the show. I'm really on it. And the show was a big deal at the time. This was a big deal to him and his friends and family
结果你所有的戏份都被剪得只剩一句台词。这种事经常发生。他说，所以他当时超级激动。他给朋友和家人打电话说，快看，快看，看这个节目。我真的在里面。而且这部剧当时影响力巨大。对他还有他的朋友和家人来说，
that he had been on it. So Dave Rogers, you are a gem. Tug, thank you so much. I want you guys to know that you can catch him on a show called Now We're Talking. It is a scripted comedy series, and he co-created it, produced it, and stars in it. And it was nominated for a WGA Award.
能出演这部剧是一件了不起的大事。所以戴夫·罗杰斯，你真是个宝藏。塔格，非常感谢你。我想让大家知道，你们可以在一部叫《我们在说话》（Now We're Talking）的剧中看到他。那是一部剧本喜剧，他是联合主创、制片人兼主演。并且它还获得过美国编剧工会奖（WGA Award）提名。
It's produced by LeBron James and Maverick Carter's company, Spring Hill. But office fans, if you check it out, you might see some office alums on there. They've got Malcolm Barrett and Andy Buckley pop up on the show. Nice. So definitely check it out,
这部剧由勒布朗·詹姆斯（LeBron James）和马verick·卡特（Maverick Carter）的公司 Spring Hill 制作。但是办公室的粉丝们，如果你去看看，你可能会在里面看到一些《办公室》的老熟人。马尔科姆·巴雷特（Malcolm Barrett）和安迪·巴克利（Andy Buckley）都在剧里客串过。太棒了。所以一定要去看看，
because this guy is amazing, Tug. Thank you so much. So we finished out this Jim and Pam story line. They're leaving the restaurant, the two of them are walking down the street, and Pam's like, that's not exactly how I had that going. Like I had a whole different prank, and she tells it to him.
因为这家伙太棒了，塔格。非常感谢你。好了，我们讲完了吉姆和潘的故事线。他们离开餐厅，两人走在街上，潘说：“事情的发展可不完全像我预想的那样。”就像她原本策划了一场完全不同的恶作剧，然后她把那个点子讲给了他听。
And then Jenna, Veda shared that you ad-libbed the end. The line about him being bald. You ad-libbed, how about we prank him on Thanksgiving about him being bald? That was all you. I was really proud of that line. I thought that was funny. Yeah, it was really funny.
然后珍娜，维达分享说结尾是你即兴发挥的。关于他秃顶的那句台词。你即兴发挥了，“要不我们在感恩节拿他秃顶开个玩笑？”那是你自创的。我当时为那句台词感到特别骄傲。我觉得挺搞笑的。对，真的很好笑。
So you had some improvs in this one, lady. I did. I really did. Now I think we should wrap up this Michael and Holly storyline, because they've arrived at Holly's charming little house in Nashua. I know.
所以你在这一集里也有不少即兴发挥呢，女士。我确实有。我真的有。现在我觉得我们应该收尾迈克尔和霍莉的故事线了，因为他们已经到达了霍莉在纳舒厄迷人的小房子。我知道。
Anthony said in the script, he wanted it to be a basement apartment. Oh. But he was like, but we don't really have basement apartments here. So they found this little house in Angelino Heights. Oh. Isn't it so cute?
安东尼在剧本里说过，他原本想设定成一个地下室公寓。哦。但他说，不过我们这里其实没有那种地下室公寓。所以他们在安杰利诺高地（Angelino Heights）找到了这座小房子。哦。是不是很可爱？
I thought it was so cute. It brought up a lot of questions for me though. Okay. If Holly was in Nashua, and she had to move her whole life and all her stuff and get rid of her house slash apartment that she had been living in and moved to Scranton, she was only in Scranton for,
我觉得超级可爱。不过这引发了我很多疑问。好吧。如果霍莉当时在纳舒厄，她不得不搬走她的整个人生和所有的东西，扔掉她一直居住的房子或公寓，然后搬到斯克兰顿，她在斯克兰顿只呆了，
I think like less than two months. And now she has to move all the way back. And it was kind of breaking my heart for her. I was glad they picked a cute location because I was thinking, oh my gosh, she just left this city. But then I thought it tracks that she would know where to get a cute place if she was from there.
我想大概不到两个月。现在她又得搬回去了。这让我为她感到揪心。我很高兴他们选了一个可爱的外景地，因为我当时想，天哪，她才刚刚离开这座城市。但后来我觉得这很合理，如果她是那儿的人，她肯定知道去哪找个可爱的地方。
Right. Maybe it's even her old place. Maybe it is. It's super cute. Super cute. Also per Dave, they were really stressed about losing light. And they were gonna be losing some of the crew
没错。也许这甚至是她以前的住处。也许是的。超级可爱。超级可爱。另外根据戴夫的说法，他们当时非常担心光线不足。而且他们会失去一些剧组工作人员
because they were gonna leave to go film the Jim and Pam proposal scene with Ken Quapas. Yeah. So we would do this sometimes. We filmed the Jim Pam proposal during this episode's week of filming. Right, because they had to build the whole thing. Sometimes the schedule just got wonky like that.
因为他们要去拍吉姆和帕姆的求婚戏，肯·夸帕斯也在。对。所以我们有时会这样。我们在本集拍摄的那周拍摄了吉姆和帕姆的求婚。没错，因为他们必须搭建整个场景。有时日程安排就是会变得这么奇怪。
So Dave was really on a time crunch here to get this filmed. Well, Michael decides he's not gonna stay. He had planned to stay for the weekend. I guess to help her unpack, it seems pretty clear that they're gonna break up. Yeah. Because of the seven hour drive
所以戴夫在赶时间把这个拍完。好吧，迈克尔决定他不呆了。他本打算留下来过周末。我猜是为了帮她拆行李，很明显他们要分手了。是的。因为要开七个小时的车
that's really a five hour drive. Only four hours, four and a half. They could have totally done it. They could have done it. I wanted to go into the TV and tell them. But. Anthony said that he wrote dialogue here for them saying goodbye and how,
那其实是五个小时的车程。只要四个小时，四个半小时。他们完全可以做到。他们本可以做到的。我想走进电视里告诉他们。但是。安东尼说他在这里为他们写了道别台词，说
well, maybe I'll see you or maybe we'll go in this and that. And then in the moment, Amy and Steve just did this really big long lingering hug. And Dave was like, that's it. Yeah. They don't need to have the dialogue. That hug tells you everything. We had a lot of mail.
嗯，也许我会再见到你，或者也许我们会这样那样。然后在那个时刻，艾米和史蒂夫只是做了一个非常深情、依依不舍的拥抱。戴夫就说，就这样。对。他们不需要台词。那个拥抱说明了一切。我们收到了很多邮件。
Oh yeah? From Chris W, Chelsea C, Hanlon H and many others just asking a couple of questions. Number one, how was Michael planning to get back to Scranton if he and Holly hadn't broken up? Right, neither of them have a car. That was the other thing. Did Holly not bring a car to Nashua?
哦，是吗？克里斯·W、切尔西·C、汉伦·H以及许多其他人问了几个问题。第一，如果迈克尔和霍莉没有分手，迈克尔原本打算怎么回斯克兰顿？对啊，他们两个都没车。那是另一回事。霍莉去纳舒厄没带车吗？
What'd she do with her car? Did she leave it in Scranton? I don't know. They didn't tow it. I noticed, I looked for it. Poor Holly has just gotten dropped off with all her stuff, a mattress in like, you know, plastic wrap. No one is helping her unpack and she has no car
她对她的车做了什么？她把它留在斯克兰顿了吗？我不知道。他们没有把它拖走。我注意到了，我找过了。可怜的霍莉就这样被放下，带着她所有的东西，一个用塑料膜包裹的床垫。没人帮她拆行李，她也没有车
and she's dressed for work. Yeah. That's how we leave Holly and Nashua. I know. This whole storyline ends with such an amazing scene of Michael and Daryl in the car driving back. Dave was really stressed because like you said, they were losing light.
而且她还穿着工作服。对。这就是我们离开纳舒厄的霍莉的方式。我知道。整个故事的结尾是迈克尔和达里尔在车里开车回去的精彩场景。戴夫压力很大，因为就像你说的，光线在消失。
Yeah, he said Randall, our camera operator was going, come on, we gotta get this now, we gotta get it now. The sun was setting, but didn't it make for such a beautiful backdrop? Yes. It just meant that they didn't get a lot of takes. They had to nail it. Anthony said he loved that it was getting dark
对，他说我们的摄像师兰德尔一直在喊，快点，我们现在得拍这个，我们现在得拍这个。太阳正在下山，但这不就成了一个美丽的背景吗？是的。这只是意味着他们没拍很多条。他们必须一次成功。安东尼说他喜欢天色变暗的感觉
because you really got the sense that they spent the whole day together. I liked that too. Dave told me this is his favorite scene from the episode. Anthony said the same thing. Yeah, Anthony was very excited because this was his pitch and his idea. He talks about it right here.
因为你真的能感觉到他们一整天都在一起。我也很喜欢这样。戴夫告诉我这是他这一集中最喜欢的场景。安东尼也这么说。是的，安东尼非常兴奋，因为这是他的构思和想法。他就在这里谈论这个。
Yeah, this is my first ever episode of television that was written and got on to TV. So it holds a very near and dear place in my heart, this one, all the stuff with the breakup. And oh, the thing with them, oh my God, of course, the scene at the end where Michael's seeing the blues, that's a special moment for me in particular
是的，这是我写的第一部上电视的电视剧。所以它在我心中占据着非常特殊和亲密的位置，这一集，所有关于分手的戏份。哦，关于他们的那场戏，哦天哪，当然还有最后迈克尔看到蓝调音乐的场景，对我来说是一个特别的时刻
because I do remember pitching that in the room. And it's one of those things as a writer, so many things you pitch, they might end up in other people's scripts, but they might end up in your scripts and you're just trying to tell the story the best way you can and every once in a while you get a situation where something you pitched is in your script
因为我确实记得在编剧室里提出过这个想法。作为一名作家，很多你提出的想法可能会出现在别人的剧本里，但也可能会出现在你自己的剧本里，你只是想尽力把故事讲好，偶尔你会遇到这样的情况，你提出的想法正好在你的剧本里
and it ends up being on the show and you feel like, oh, that's amazing. That whole blues moment at the end when Michael Scott just doesn't get it, but still has the cathartic moment he needs at the end of that. I thought, I remember pitching that in the room and thinking, oh, that'll be fun to get to do
而且最后还播出了，你会觉得，哦，这太棒了。最后迈克尔·斯科特虽然不太明白，但依然获得了他需要的宣泄时刻的整个蓝调时刻。我想，我记得在编剧室里提出这个时觉得，哦，拍这个一定很有趣
and then I got to write the episode and then I got to watch it happen. And it was getting dark and it was just a perfect little moment for us. And I just remember feeling like I have the best job in the world. I know those scenes. Well, I just love that.
然后我写了这一集，然后我看着它发生。天色渐渐变暗，对我们来说这只是一个完美的时刻。我只记得当时觉得自己拥有世界上最好的工作。我很熟悉那些场景。嗯，我就是喜欢这个。
There was something so special about seeing your idea fully realized. And I just love that he shared that. Well, lady, we have one last scene. We do, you know, we don't really ever find out exactly how this Cornell interview application thing wraps up. I assume he doesn't get in, but that was never really the point.
看到自己的想法完全实现，有一种非常特别的感觉。我只是喜欢他分享这个。好了，女士们，我们还有最后一个场景。是的，你知道，我们其实从来没有真正发现这个康奈尔面试申请的事情是怎么收尾的。我猜他没考上，但这从来都不是重点。
The point of this storyline was really Angela. Angela was the point. This was Dwight was performing for her. And he's winding Andy up because he is jealous. That's right. Well, there was a whole runner. There were scenes between Angela and Andy where Andy's all worked up
这个故事情节的重点其实是安吉拉。安吉拉才是重点。这是德怀特在为她表演。他在激怒安迪因为他嫉妒。没错。其实还有一个完整的副线。安吉拉和安迪之间有一些场景，安迪非常激动
and Angela's trying to calm him down. And then Angela goes to Dwight and is like, what the heck? Here's one of those deleted scenes. Why are you doing this to Andy? You once told me that Andy and I had different strengths. Well, he can't do what I can do. I can get into Cornell, but he doesn't know how to make food and shelter
而安吉拉试图让他平静下来。然后安吉拉去找德怀特说，到底怎么回事？这里是其中一个被删减的场景。你为什么要这样对安迪？你曾经告诉我，我和安迪有不同的长处。嗯，他做不到我能做的事。我能考上康奈尔，但他不知道怎么用金毛寻回犬
from a golden retriever. Even if you do somehow get in, that's not gonna make me leave Andy. No, but it'll make you respect him less. Yes, that's true. Oh, I said it stayed in. I know because Dwight does get what he wants, right? Yeah.
制作食物和住所。即使你真的考上了，也不会让我离开安迪。不，但这会让你更不尊重他。是的，这倒也是。哦，我说过它保留下来了。我知道，因为德怀特确实得到了他想要的，对吧？是的。
I think Andy unravels in front of Angela. And whether Dwight gets into Cornell or not, she didn't care for it. No, not at all. And now we have this tag. Yeah. Where Andy's gonna pay back Dwight. But of course, it's just so embarrassing.
我认为安迪在安吉拉面前崩溃了。不管德怀特是否考上康奈尔，她根本不在乎。不，一点也不。现在我们有了这个尾声。是的。安迪要报复德怀特。但当然，这太尴尬了。
In fact, at 20 minutes, 51 seconds is one of my most popular memes. What, when you're rolling your eyes? Yes, Andy walks in dressed as a farmer with no shirt on and beats, and my character rolls her eyes and then puts her head into her hand. Oh, we had a fan question.
事实上，在20分51秒时，这是我最受欢迎的表情包之一。什么，当你翻白眼的时候？是的，安迪穿着农民的衣服光着膀子走进来，手里拿着甜菜，而我的角色翻了个白眼，然后把头埋进手里。哦，我们有一个粉丝提问。
People wanted to know, did Rain actually take a bite out of a beat at the end of the episode? Yes, he did, and that was improvised. Yes, and Veda said he did it in the last take. Very smart Rain, if you're going to do it. Yeah, it was scripted that Andy tries to bite the beat and that line about, oh, you're supposed to cook it first.
人们想知道，雷恩在这一集结尾时真的咬了一口甜菜吗？是的，他咬了，那是即兴发挥的。是的，韦达说他是最后一条拍的。非常聪明的雷恩，如果你打算这么做的话。是的，剧本写的是安迪试图咬甜菜，还有那句台词，哦，你应该先把它煮熟。
That was in the script, but the button of Dwight being able to bite a beat, that was all Rain. All Rain, Wilson. You guys, that was employee transfer. Yes, and we wanna give a huge thanks to all the people who helped gather information on this episode.
那是在剧本里，但德怀特能够咬一口甜菜的那个包袱，全都是雷恩自己发挥的。全都是雷恩·威尔逊。各位，那是员工调动。是的，我们要向所有帮助收集本集信息的人表示巨大的感谢。
It was a bunch of people. Thank you, thank you to James Carey, Dave Rogers, Alicia Raycraft, Phil Shea, Anthony Farrell, and Tug Corker for sharing your memories. One final shout out for Tug. He and his wife own a wine bar. What? It's Santa Monica, Angela. It's called Esther's.
有很多人。谢谢，谢谢詹姆斯·凯瑞、戴夫·罗杰斯、艾丽西亚·雷克拉夫、菲尔·谢伊、安东尼·法雷尔和塔格·科克分享你们的回忆。最后向塔格致敬。他和他的妻子拥有一家红酒吧。什么？在圣莫尼卡，安吉拉。它叫埃丝特酒吧。
He's invited us to come down. Oh, what? Have some wine and cheese with them. Tug, we are there. Right? Well, he and his wife also do a podcast together called The Long Finish. You can find them on Instagram at the long finish. Here's what they do.
他邀请我们去。哦，什么？和他们一起喝点酒吃点奶酪。塔格，我们一定去。对吧？嗯，他和他的妻子还一起主持一个播客叫《长局》。你可以在Instagram上搜索the long finish找到他们。他们是这样做的。
They open a bottle of wine and they discuss their life as they work together and raise three kids. He has a three week old baby. Tug, right? Bless your heart. Right? You're in the weeds. They are in the weeds,
他们打开一瓶酒，一边工作一边抚养三个孩子，并讨论他们的生活。他有一个三个月大的婴儿。塔格，对吧？上帝保佑你。对吧？你们现在焦头烂额。他们确实焦头烂额，
but they still do this podcast about their life together. And Tug, we're coming to have wine with you guys. We sure are. And you guys, if you haven't watched the bloopers for this one, they're a must watch. Go to the DVD box set. They're so good. I'm so jealous I don't have this one.
但他们仍然在做这个关于他们共同生活的播客。塔格，我们要去和你们一起喝一杯。我们一定会去的。伙计们，如果你们还没看过这一集的滑稽失误花絮，那绝对不能错过。去看看DVD套装。太棒了。我很嫉妒我没有这一集。
We got to get it for you. I know. Well, you guys, sometimes life is a highway. And you got to ride it all night long. We'll see you next week. See you next week. And this song will be in your head forever now. You know it.
我们得给你弄一套。我知道。好吧，伙计们，生活有时就像一条高速公路。你得一路驰骋。我们下周见。下周见。现在这首歌会永远留在你们脑海里了。你们懂的。
If you're going my way. Woo! All night long. Oh, yeah. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher.
如果你走我的路。呜！一整天。哦，是的。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。
Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubakow. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布巴科夫。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月，请使用优惠码OFFICE。本集暂时还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。